I did Why did Pastoki do this to me
Why did she do this to me?
But those who don't know, past Doki left Quarant Doki in the
basement level, which apparently I found out is one of the
scariest areas in this game.
She got me real good, didn't she?
Oh, yes, she did.
She got me real good.
Curse you, past Doki.
cookie got away with it again oh anyway um that's why we're
also streaming at 12 30 p.m pst at the moment because um
because you know the sun is still out and uh so the sun
light is still showing so i still i still you know whenever
i finish today's playthrough at least like i'm not going to
think I'm gonna get grabbed by anybody no it's it's so it's
less scary when the Sun is out so I have that on my side NSD
and seven thank you for the five gifted chips thank you
thank you oh yes other than that I bought a switch to guys I
I finally did it but you don't have window yes but
eventually when I finished today's playthrough, I finished
today's stream, I have to leave the room, there's no bed in
my office, I still have to go to bed, like, anyway, um, I
finally bought a Switch 2 for one game, for one game and one
game only, and it was for Pokopia, for those who don't know
what the fuck is Pokapia is the new Pokemon Animal Crossing
slash Minecraft hybrid that they're releasing exclusively on
the Switch and apparently the reviews were in and it is the
currently the highest rated Pokemon game of all time and I
was just I know that's fucking crazy game that has nothing
to do with like you know the usual mainstream line the core
gameplay of itself is currently the highest rated pokemon
game of all time of all the pokemon games including all the
spin-offs all the mainstream games is the highest one and
the craziest part the reason the one that actually made me
by a switch to is that it is one point higher than Resident
Evil regular
reviews PocoPiF is one point higher than Resident Evil
Requiem so I was like well I gotta try it like now like if
it is that good if it's even better than Resident Evil
Requiem by one point I mean I guess i have to try it at that
point paid for five did 10 oh yeah because grace does grace
drag the whole review down that's why um so yeah anyway uh
i'm getting switched today apparently it's arriving today
and i did watch like i watched some of the videos like the
the showcase of pocopia and apparently the reason why it's
like apparently very intricate to the point where like
there's like redstone mechanics in pocopia i mean i won't be
doing any of that i'm not smart enough for that type of shit
but like i'm not that type of minecrafter but apparently you
can build like roller coasters music music in it like the
music box stuff they have it implemented into pocopia like
similar to minecraft so like there's like uh there's like
roller coaster mechanics and like music boxes and redstone
mechanics in pocopia so like they literally like have like
some crazy ass like engineering shit in there so uh I
thought that was really neat I'm not gonna do any of that
shit obviously uh like obviously that I'm not gonna be doing
any of that but you know it's cool for the people who can do
it you know cool for the cool for the player plate base that
has an IQ above uh one which is me so so yeah I'm looking
forward to trying like animal crossing the only like okay to
be fair i do not decorate it like in animal crossing i don't
do any of the the renovation shit because like i i do not
i'm not creative enough for that type of stuff um um but
like uh i love interacting with like the villagers and stuff
and i love like the little the little stuff you the little
errands and stuff you get to do i think it's very cute i
love the animal crossing general so i'm looking forward to
pocopia um it's like a little slice of I escape my life to
live their lives.
Live the sweet, simple life of Pokemon.
Ozney, thank you.
Thank you.
You leave the office to sleep.
What kind of workaholic are you?
Ozney, thank you.
The Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you.
The Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Dokey, have you seen a game Twitch pick for the recent
rivals?
Yes, I have.
I thought it was really funny.
women's month okay for those who didn't see the well to see
the um the yesterday's drama um they announced the twitch
rivals for to celebrate women's month and the game of choice
was uh what was it the cooking game um i forgot what it was
called but it was basically a cooking game and oh sorry and
then people were like i'm women's month but then the funny
thing is that it was it was overcooked but it was voted by
the women participating and then later on it was revealed
they're like um the game was actually voted by the women
participating and then people like oh
oh yeah they they voted for it but to be fair the game
choices it was literally like
filling prophecy because here were the game choices that
they had which of course was going to lead them to vote for
overcooked it was literally um well it was clear the
expedition 33 challenge wherever the fuck the challenge
would be um uh was it hollow night challenge um overcooked
or the super chicken horse game so i was like obviously out
of all those four choices for games be like the most easy to
implement and play like in a competition like so so they
were like sabotaged to vote overcooked or yeah i take
overcooked i would vote for overcooked too if those were my
choices like i mean maybe hollow night but then like hollow
night is so it's not beginner friendly like you know it's
not very like what's the word it's not very easy to um to
get into if you're not like if you're just a casual gamer
yeah yeah they could have had like other party games like
maybe fall guys or like the the animal beat up game the
animal party game yeah the skill ceiling is a lot higher the
game was literally rigged from the start and then the i
think like the most i think it was i thought it was like um
really funny they're like i can't believe twitch would do
this would give these choice, like do this to them.
And then the people participants were like, we sort of voted
for it.
They're like, the women participants were like, we voted for
it.
And then, yeah, I can't believe Twitch would do this.
But to be fair, I would vote for it too if those were my
choices.
Like, they were not very great choices.
what like expedition 33 hollow night um super uh what is a
chicken horse super uh chicken horse game whatever the fuck
it is or overcooked i would pick overcooked too it's the
easiest game for the competition
yeah but it's a challenge so it must have been like
whichever team the thing is expedition 33 like you know like
parries and like all yeah ultimate chicken horse yeah um
expedition 33 is not very beginner casual friendly in terms
of like you know there's parries mechanics and two and i
assume the challenge for it is um would be like complete a
certain stage at a certain time so it'd be like a speed run
challenge so it's not very casual friendly because not
everyone can fucking speed run because usually because
that's usually what it is if it's like a challenge complete
a certain objective first and that's not very beginner like
like beginner or casual friendly for people to get into um
anyway other than that uh also i just realized uh apparently
i thought it was really funny but i just realized that um
every resident evil game that played on this channel has
leon as the main character i played resident evil 2 resident
evil 4 and then Resident Evil 9.
So every Resident Evil game is literally me playing as Leon.
I've just been every iteration of Leon.
And that's how I like it.
And that's how it's gonna be.
Any new Resident Evil game that comes out, if it doesn't
have Leon, it's never on this channel.
Doing it for Leon.
I don't care if Resident Evil 10 comes out.
And it's like the newest game ever.
If it has no Leon, you won't see me there.
When they remake all Leon games.
No, not every version of Leon.
Here's a few extra seconds of solitude.
My birthday was Sunday.
Could I get a happy birthday for my Oshie?
Of course, Minler.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Minler.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yeah, it's going to be like Resident Evil 15.
Leon is on his wheelchair he's 80 years old and they're like
we need you Leon for one last job only you can complete this
Leon women only want one thing and it's Leon look at the
super chat buddy thank you thank you I need a mod that just
and I won't play the new Resident Evil game unless the mod
adds Leon into Unless someone adds a mod where I could just
play as Leon as the main character.
Apparently there is that.
I was looking at the modding stuff for Resident Evil 9
because already people are starting modding stuff already.
And apparently you can substitute Leon for Chris.
There's like a mod for that.
So whenever Resident Evil 10 comes out, I'll only play it
when there's a Leon mod.
Yeah, every skin Leon over every main character.
that until like um until I saw a tweet that was saying how
like um every new Resident Evil game has just been like like
you know all the remakes and everything all the new Resident
Evil games that have come out last three Resident Evil games
that have come out it's just all Leon and I was like wait a
minute those were the last three Resident Evil games I
played on this chat it's Resident Evil 2 Resident Evil 2
remake Resident Evil 4 remake and then Resident Evil 9 And I
was thinking, wait a minute, that's all the games I played
on this channel.
It's literally just all Leon.
So that's the only way you're going to get me to play the
new Resident Evil game.
It's a pattern.
Oops, all Leon.
Anyway, I guess I've stalled enough.
I guess I've stalled enough I guess yeah it's tradition I
guess it's time to play Resident Evil 9 the basement lover
no dad update he's just sleeping like there hasn't really
okay no there is a dad update but I'll give I'll tell the
story um i'll tell the story later uh people and members
know this story already because it's a it was a member
exclusive story but i'll i'll tell this i'll tell this dad
story later um aphelion thank you for the five gifted ships
thank you thank you do it do it for leon do it for leon okay
i need to move
Oh God, I fucking hate you, Grace.
I hate you so much.
Oh my God, fuck you, Grace.
No, fuck the FBI director for, I know, I knew it, I was
like, I was like in the intro when I was saying this, I was
like, it's so fucking weird that the FBI director sent me,
the data analyst girl, without a partner backup like what
the fuck god I'm like she's like an office lady and she was
like yeah go in there by yourself and with no backup or
partner and I'm like I swear to God it's like an inside job
I so like why the fuck would you send her in she has like
literally no muscle in her arms she has no muscle at all
she's like a fucking stick mr.
peeps fun thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
one of five gift dishes thank you thank you uh solid thank
you super chat thank you thank you no worries don't keep i
got you please stall longer since it's my birthday here's my
doki attacks glad i've been trying to go for you another
early year thank you for the super chat thank you for
helping me stall a little longer happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear solid happy birthday to
you yeah happy birthday yeah Let me send the lady with
actual trauma to the place where her mom died with no
fucking backup.
And a tiny ass pistol.
Like what the fuck is she going to do with this tiny ass
gun?
I'm surprised she could even like control the recoil of the
Requiem gun.
Like at that point when she should have like broke her bones
when she shoots that gun.
She Like, every time she shot that gun, she should, like,
break a wrist or some shit.
Oh, that's her personal gun, too.
She was not even issued a gun at a crime scene.
That is so fucked up.
She didn't even have a gun issued to her for the crime.
Oh, my God.
I hate this.
Curse you.
pastor why would you do this to me
okay everyone's dead the plan went to shit I'm the only one
left in this god-forsaking place I try to escape but what's
the point I can still see my colleagues be eating alive like
an endless loop playing over and over in my head let it stop
please oh yeah anyway I didn't even realize anyway
skaterbirds here I figured like you know the thumbnail had
skaterbird in it oh my god oh my god i wish there was more
light here i spiral thank you with a super chat thank you
thank you it's my birthday oh it's your birthday happy
birthday happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday your dear spiral happy birthday to you oh my god i
hate it i fucking hate you i hate you so much i why why why
oh my god also i need to let this out because okay i've read
about the final puzzle um for those who don't know uh
resident this game included a um a little uh little final
puzzle for uh which is like the hardest puzzle in this game
it's a little easter egg and it got data mine to for it got
data mined unfortunately um for the solution which sucks
because um you know uh the fun part was like all the
community getting together trying to figure out the um
trying to figure out like the solution to the puzzle and
it's like very convoluted very complicated and everything so
in the end like two people data mined the solution for it
and they had to reverse like reverse um reverse process it
to like figure out like why how it led to how to it led to
the solution and yeah it was like hot zombies level
difficulty um anyway i wanted to mention the the final
puzzle because um in the puzzle at the final puzzle grace
read press the buttons herself without needing fucking emily
to press the buttons for her so she can do a process
thinking and didn't need the fucking blind girl to read the
braille like that is what i learned about the final puzzle
so in the end grace didn't fucking need the blind girl and
that she wouldn't have got she wouldn't have got kidnapped
because we wouldn't have had to bring her to the braille
room
Like, she could have fucking did a process of elimination
and trialed and erred her wake into the solution.
She didn't need her.
Because in the final puzzle, she pressed the braille buttons
herself.
Like, and that's what I learned.
about the final puzzle like but yes there was a guy that
ended up finding the solution to the final puzzle um without
having to data mine like without before the data my solution
came out but like he didn't even know how he got the answer
he was like because like in one of the solutions for it one
of the steps for it like a ball appears under the stairway
or some shit and then he they were like how did he get the
dog he must have cheated and then the guy was like no it
just appeared like he's like i don't even know how the how
the doll appeared it just it just appeared but you can get
this doll at the end of the stairway and then you can
complete the solution like the mirror was so confused and
then um apparently he accidentally stumbled onto the
solution because he was like he was um because in one of the
steps to the final puzzle you have to afk in a certain area
for like at least 15 minutes.
So you can AFK them longer than 15 minutes.
But like you have to stay in that one area for 15 minutes.
And then also not kill any of the zombies after that.
And then the guy was, and then also after not killing the
zombies, you have to go to the toilets and flush at least
eight times.
And then the doll will spawn.
And then everyone was like,
stumbled upon the solution and he was like oh yeah i was afk
there because i didn't know what to do he was like i got
really stuck in the puzzle so i was running around for at
least 15 minutes trying to figure out what to do in this
room because i didn't know what to do and he and then
they're like okay then why didn't you kill any zombies and
he was like i didn't have any ammo left and then the guy and
then they're like okay then why did you flush the toilets at
least eight times and he's like i thought it was funny i was
just fucking around in the bathrooms so when i flushed it so
i he didn't know how many times he's flushed it but like you
have to flush it just at least eight times so you can flush
more than eight times so the guy was literally just like
flushing the toilets for fun because he was like he he just
spamming it he's like
And then the doll is fine.
And so, like, he literally just...
He literally just stumbled.
Like, fucking was tripping and falling into the solution
himself.
The bro is a real protagonist.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Alright, stalling done.
Yeah, you can't have stalled my super clever and difficult
pussed out accident.
I totally go.
But he didn't know how.
He was just like, yeah, the dog just spawned.
And it was like, what do you mean the dog just spawned?
You must have hacked your game.
Like, what the fuck do you mean?
Like, how did you get that dog?
He's like, I don't know.
It's just spawned.
Hmm.
Okay.
And then when the data miners come up, people are like, oh.
So that's how he did it.
I fucking hate this.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I hate this level.
Oh, I think this is worse than the jail level.
This is absolutely worse than the jail level.
Oh my god, it's so dark.
It's so...
No, it's very quiet.
It's not muted.
I swear to God to you guys.
It is so...
This game, it is so quiet right now, and that's what I hate.
It's so fucking quiet.
Oh my god, what do you mean it's growling?
Oh my god, is that my stomach?
Why is it growling?
Oh my god, what the fuck is this?
Oh my god, Grace, please get something to eat.
Please, Grace, you don't need to go on a diet.
You're beautiful, just the way you are.
Okay, that has to be the safe room.
okay thank god all right we are in the safe room okay okay
it's fine everything is fine i don't need the requiem or
what i definitely don't need the coins oh my god okay you
don't need the id level or whatever this is we'll see your
cursor yes because i'm oh
I have a little surprise for you guys if we make it though
if we make it if we
there's a little surprise for you guys if we make it today
if
okay where am I all right what do you mean you'll find out
soon well not soon oh there she is okay there she's safe
thank god it's not my birthday but can i get some well
wishes of course you can mr broken bond thank you the super
chat thank you thank you i hope you're doing well i don't
even know if we make it guys oh girl is currently occupying
the basement we plan in the corner by taking advantage of
subjects intolerance to life place high intestinally
ultraviolet lamps throughout the area once this is complete
we'll begin our operation to eliminate the subject don't
think they made it i don't think they made it guys oh my god
all right here we go all right back into hell the pits of
hell oh my god oh he has to be not dead oh my god okay
whatever how about you i fucking knew it i fucking knew it I
knew you were gonna like come alive somehow
Yeah, I don't like that I don't know if I can I feel like I
don't know It's gonna be rough Like he's gonna turn into a
blister head I'm trying to Oh shit nah Okay I'm trying to
bet on the fact that Maybe I'll get like a headshot you know
like oh no he's gonna turn into a no fuck okay it's fine
it's okay
okay it's okay it's okay everything will be okay
Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not my birthday, Doki.
Forget about Metti.
I must know you finished playing the Mass Effect trilogy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I only did part one of Mass Effect, but it doesn't exist no
more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zaku, thank you for the super chat.
Emily, wake up.
Just give me the thing.
Emily, wake up and just give me the course.
I'll come back for you later.
I swear.
to god i swear you're like just just give me the quits and
i'll come back for you spy was lying i tear a magnum out of
existence you're gonna super chat thank you thank you there
is an archive if you look hard enough also i don't know how
sound guys here but i did adjust the uh get here emily emily
please wake up emily emily we i just need the quits i'll
come you how dare you guys imply i would just leave an
orphan to die guys kepler you think i'm that evil
are you implying that i would leave an orphan child who is
blind by the way and could be uh could be paraplegic because
she couldn't for some fucking reason She wouldn't walk by
herself And just leave her alone to die in that jail cell
You gotta insert the three joint plugs and pull the left
lever If you're crazy enough to open the cells The joint
plugs are currently being used to power other areas I marked
their location Oh my god on the map Removing them will cut
the electricity So you better be extra sure before Okay
that's five That's not five But that's five I'm gonna open
it oh my god okay okay all right I could I'm gonna make the
actually I'm gonna make the injector just in case a blister
comes up all right it's all right we're safe Emily wake up
Emily Emily please please just throw me just throw me the
fucking oh no oh no no i could technically kill them right
now oh my god no i should just kill them when they're all oh
no all right it's fine just suck up the blood uh zaku they
give the super chat thank you thank you oh no okay it's okay
it's okay um i just have to oh i just have to have to go
over there oh all
right okay oh okay i'm in the light technically
i don't rather turn off the light mine's sad not again it's
okay she doesn't know she doesn't know She's blind as well.
Oh my god, she is blind as well.
Oh my god, but I can't see as well.
Oh my god, I remember she's just as blind as her.
Oh my god, where is she?
Where the fuck is she?
Can't tell.
I'm blind, she's blind, it's an equal fight.
She's 10 feet tall.
I'm like 4 foot 5.
A very fair fight.
She has Ungabunga Gorilla Strength.
I break my bones when I shoot my one pistol.
We're just the same.
Oh, I don't like that sound.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Joint plug.
One.
Okay.
It's okay.
Why is everything so fucking far?
Taking the toolbox is a boiler room for repairs.
The quality of blood the laboratory receives has gone
downhill.
We will notify from above to take immediate actions.
Look like some problems during the separation process is
sublime.
Going to do some work on it.
Okay, in the boiler.
Where the fuck is the boiler room?
How fucking am I supposed to know where the fuck the boiler
room is?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Yeah, but I don't want to shoot it, though.
It's a waste of...
I don't have a...
I'm not Leon.
I don't...
I have very, very limited amount of ammo.
The boiler room has a boiler in it, Doki.
Okay.
I assume.
It's okay.
I'll go.
Is there anything here?
Must be something here, right?
Melina.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The fuck is the chain jingling from?
I can't tell.
Oh, dark!
Okay, she's blind, so it should be fine.
Yeah, I can't access this yet, I...
Oh, wait, that's the boiler.
This is not the boiler room?
That's gonna come alive, isn't it?
Okay, I have light here.
Okay, there's a boiler there.
Does that mean that's the boiler room?
oh okay no you're definitely alive but when will you come
alive that's the question not now
oh he drops nothing all right that's cool it might have been
a waste but like i just didn't want to take my chances all
right he's gonna be stuck in the in the forever dream now oh
i should have oh i should have saved it for that guy bro was
just thinking should have napped on the job that's his fault
he's not paid to nap you don't nap on company hours
Yeah, and I wonder if that room is important.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Kick!
Alright, because I want to read this.
Alright, at the 12 subjects we were provided with were
confirmed infected and reduced by blood.
At the processing area, we'll be able to increase the
turnover rate even more thanks to increased stock from our
supply chain.
We have already started processing in today's edition.
There can be a grab all of...
Don't don't.
Yes, I can't do anything about that.
Bye.
Oh my god, that's a key that I don't have.
Surely there's nobody inside the tunnel.
Alright, lot pick.
Did what open?
Yeah, what you gonna do now, huh?
Stupid.
Can't do shit.
Okay, was that a lockpick of it?
Was that a lockpick on the right or a key?
Guys, what is that?
What is that over there?
Do I need a key or can I lockpick that?
Stupid zombies, you're too tall.
Do I actually need that key?
Alright, let's just leave.
Okay.
Wait, was there anything interesting here?
Forklift, empty bottle.
Okay, nothing important here.
We do not have any of these things.
What's that in front of me?
What is...
What...
What was that in front of me just now?
Excuse me?
um why is she in my tunnel i thought this tunnel was made
for me
okay goodbye goodbye oh it's fine everything will be fine
everything will be fine everything will be okay
all right so i've opened that so i guess i'll go back and
grab my power distribute oh wait so I need the key for that,
though.
I guess I'll do it here.
Oh, my God.
I hate this level.
This is the worst level.
This is the worst level yet.
That's stupid.
He doesn't know I'm right behind him.
All right, let's just go back.
We're going to go back.
We don't have the key to grab.
this we're just gonna slowly walk back
and then and then i can grab this go to the tunnel unlock
the thing oh my god i'm so smart okay i remove this go to
the tunnel go
to the tunnel here oh my god the tunnel requires a plug oh
That's fine.
I'm in my safe spot, though.
She can't show up because there's light here.
It's okay.
This is fine.
I made it a little complicated than it needed to be.
Wait, I can grab the plug.
But the plug, isn't the plug hidden behind this door?
Okay.
Oh my god, it wasn't a plug.
It was the little power.
Oh my god, it was a power.
Okay.
Oh, that was an accident.
Let me...
Let me kick you again.
It's fine.
And then... Oh my god, it's still a key.
Get out of here.
That's fine.
Shirley's dead now.
Alright, Shirley, there's no way he's going to turn into a
blister head.
Ha ha.
It's okay.
No way, guys.
There's no way.
Shirley is not going to...
Shirley, he's going to stay dead forever.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, maybe he'll get eaten by a bigger monster.
Rules of nature.
Oh, so sound guy.
I have adjusted the audio a bit.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
She's right behind.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
it's okay it's okay oh my god what do you mean now it's not
the time for what do you what do you what do you what do you
what do you mean what do you mean this is the safe room i'm
safe in the safe room aren't i if i'm safe in the safe room
it should always be the time for that wait what what do you
mean oh my god she won't she doesn't know i'm so Sneaky.
You can't sleep with the monsters around you.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is she?
There's no way she's still spawn camping me.
There is no way she's spawn camping me right now.
She actually is.
Okay, she's gone.
Okay, we're safe.
We're safe.
Wait, did I grab the other's power spark?
I did, okay.
And then we go here to maybe get this.
It's so far!
Where the fuck is this place?
Where the fuck is that?
He doesn't know.
He's so stupid.
Alright, where does this...
okay let there be light hmm oh hello sir let me just walk
around you all right let me go okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay I'm gonna use it I need my knife back.
Where'd my knife go?
Where did...
Where did my knife go?
The knife was sticking out of his fucking face.
So I would assume it would just, you know, pounce out.
The knife is now everywhere.
It blew up.
I have a lockpick.
Thank God.
I'm saving these lockpick for days.
I'm ready for my heist.
Okay, rare metal.
I can make more.
All right, at least I can make more of...
Oh, I can make a cocktail.
Is it worth it?
I'm going to make one cocktail.
one yeah I don't know what the fuck I'm gonna do with a
cocktail oh I know when the when the prison cell opens oh my
god that I'm so genius I'm a fucking genius oh sure that's
not gonna electrocute me right anything here oh the square
socket wrench all right we have to turn off the power here
he has no head that's good I just how do I hmm water
electricity am I immune
hmm I wonder if maybe I'm immune guys he said I'm special
yeah I have rubber I've rubber soles on my shoes I don't
think I'm special yes I don't understand the fuck am I
supposed okay it's really like a secret passage all right
because I opened this
But, like, the only way is I have to go through this...
Oh, it's the other area.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
I have to check the last socket room, which is here.
Oh, you're definitely not dead.
Oh, I hate this.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
all right here we go and now move this away oh my god grace
you're so smart oh my god you're so smart you make grace so
smart right now oh no at least i'm full hp
that's okay guys i'm full hp now
It's okay.
I'm full.
I'm full HP.
I'm so healthy.
Okay, maybe if I just run, just run, Doki, just run, run to
the other safe spot.
Okay, okay, she can't get you here.
There's light.
God said, let there be life.
All right, we got another lockpick.
Okay, that guy in there.
That's a jump scare.
There's no way.
Oh, wait, no, he has no head.
Never mind, there is a way.
Never mind.
No head.
That's like, there's no way.
Never mind.
I'm pretty sure these did did.
okay I got the socket what do I need oh and then I what do I
need the wrench for
it's a wrench for this area chat no head is it for that I
remember where to use the wrench for the workshop somewhere
else I forgot where the wrench was supposed to go.
Which how we could?
There was a new area?
The fuck am I supposed to use this?
Here?
There was an area here.
Okay, I do not remember this.
Where am I?
Alright.
Oh my god, she's there!
Oh my!
It's like it's okay.
I'm safe.
Oh my god.
Where's the door?
I...
She's right behind me.
No, no.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
She like fucking grabbed half of Grace.
I'm not okay.
I
She fucking got half of me Like what the fuck am I supposed
to do in that situation?
Yeah Good thing you're at fully
Don't look back don't look back.
That's what she wants.
I That's what she wants.
Oh.
So I have.
Oh, wait.
Medinjector.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Fold.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's...
Okay.
I have one Medinjector.
Gotta make it count.
Yeah.
Are you kidding me?
I can't use a Requiem gun.
I gotta save it for Resident Evil 10.
Put the scrap away.
But what if I need it?
I can actually make more.
I'll make more of this.
True.
Guys.
What if I need it for Resident Evil 10, guys?
You don't understand.
Was it for this?
Was it for the forklift, chat?
I think it was for the forklift like
yeah i'll need this go
oh wait i was supposed to go there oh my god didn't matter
oh my god it didn't matter part two
okay all right then you remind me of the plush i may not
play the game but i'll pick up the plushie yeah thank you
the super chat thank you thank you yes for those who don't
know the um the apex watson plush uh the apex watson dokey
plush collab ends in less than a week in five days and then
it won't be uh it won't be sold anymore so Grab it for a
little memory.
A little memory for...
Oh, it's right here, right?
Little momentum.
My anniversary and the Apex anniversary.
What the fuck?
I don't know, I'm just like hoping that maybe...
No, there's clear...
No way he's going to turn into a blister head.
Ha ha!
Oh wait.
Alright, I'm...
Putting all my gotcha luck onto the headburst.
Alright, I gotta grab this too.
I have enough time.
It takes 20 minutes to get up.
See?
Alright, I'm safe.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I actually was ready to go through.
How the fuck am I supposed to get to the other side?
What?
He said let there be light.
Then what?
The elevator?
Alright, he has to be dead.
Will you turn into a blister head?
Nah, there's no way.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
How do I call the elevator?
There's no way.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so healthy.
There's no way.
It'll be fine.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
The possibility of that is almost zero.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I actually really need this.
God, Gurs needs meds for days.
okay ladder time you need a zip launcher find the nearest
bad delivery pod in arkham thank you let's reach out thank
you thank you let's grab everything else before we do
anything crazy
what's this i need a key which i don't have yet oh there you
go I need the key, which I do have.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
Soon.
Soon I can have an armory pocket like Leon.
The saddest part is like, this is only like one-eighth of
Leon's pockets right now.
All right.
Now I have a map.
Yay.
She's forklift certified.
I remove that What drain the pond
No Okay then what the fuck
Then what the fuck
How the fuck do I drain that
Okay Oh A floor plant turning in a valve it on the opposite
side or drain it yeah but how do we get to the opposite side
oh all right we gotta leave the plug here grab my two plugs
go on a fucking journey okay here you blackbone thank you
the super chat thank you thank you hey joki how are you
doing kind of new here sadly won't be able to watch
mainstream because i'm like my european ass Time zone sucks.
I try as I enjoy your...
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for stopping by.
Even though the whole time zone is so, I really appreciate
it.
I hope you enjoy your time here.
As a new dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Got the key.
Don't worry.
I was like, do I got the key?
I started to worry though.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, can I go this way?
Monster appears in front of me.
Maybe I should go straight ahead.
Zero survival instinct.
Let me go straight ahead.
See,
I told you.
No blister head.
It was a risk I was willing to take.
Now I go from here.
Oh, no.
Surely she won't.
Surely she won't appear in front of me, guys.
No way.
There's no way.
See, I'm safe here.
I'm safe in my little tunnel.
I was like, we bought it.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, hey, little guy.
Hey, little rat guy.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, shall leave, right?
Surely shall leave.
There's nothing interesting here.
It's just a stupid old tunnel.
Just a stupid old room.
There's no toys here.
There's nothing fun here.
It's so boring.
Perfect angle, though.
She's blind.
She can't see my light.
She's like blind.
She's blind.
What's she gonna do?
Read the braille off my flashlight?
At best, like, she will smell me before she can see the
light.
I have to worry about her echolocation, not my fucking
flashlight.
feel the smell the light she can taste it come and God said
let there be light that's right we forklift certify this ha
ha ha what you gonna do now oh my god she started walking
closer to me towards me I got scared what's this oh is this
the 15 minute shit oh this was the 15 minute shit right I
don't know what it's supposed to do oh shit what the fuck
Okay, it's fine.
No, okay, so the thing is, the final puzzle was like, oh my
god, he's just staring at me.
I hate that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Boom!
All right.
There should be enough time to move this, right?
Wait, which way am I moving?
Ah!
No!
That's the fuck!
Okay, how much HP do I have?
I'm fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, just to be sure.
Alright, I'm pushing him away.
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
Alright, it's fine.
I'll grab his blood too It's a gray sandwich Alright, I got
an idea
Alright It's gonna And then I have to Oh my Okay, and then I
swap Oh no, reversal
Okay, throw it the needle Oh god, okay And then
okay eventually i'll get there eventually there's gonna be a
huge gap here for me
eventually okay this is close enough this is close enough
all right the fuck okay that's why i have enough ammo for
this i believe in the no blister head run.
I believe.
There we go.
No blister head.
There's no way.
I believe.
I'm trusting my RNG right now.
I'm trusting the RNG.
Surely they won't turn into blister heads, right?
Surely.
Oh yeah, basically this.
Was it this?
The guy waited 15 minutes for this, basically, because he
didn't understand the puzzle.
He waited 15 minutes for the final puzzle.
Because he couldn't understand how to pass the pathway.
He was so fucking confused.
He just literally AFKed and he's like, what the fuck do I
do?
Like, how do we get here?
How do I get here who put a types of an employee who wanted
to chase his dreams you not see this he was trying to get
published he didn't even be stuck in the basement forever
i'm just gonna the more you apparently the more you chuck in
the more zombies there are
guys i'm not doing the final puzzle
I'm not doing the final puzzle Because you know how to
complete the final puzzle It requires me to play this game
On New Game Plus
No, he was stuck He was stuck on the puzzle He didn't know
how to He didn't know what to do with the lever It's too
late It's already too late
Oh All right, here we go.
Here we go.
That's fine.
We're not gonna get up from here.
See?
Everything will be okay.
You're just getting pro- Oh.
Oh.
It's okay.
You're just gonna get processed, guys.
Okay, it's fine.
Watch this.
And then, boom!
Get processed!
It's alright.
What the fuck?
Get processed!
Oh, shit.
more meat for the grinder blood for the blood guy that's
right I ain't afraid of you I got my strats a process strat
oh shit wait oh it's okay it's okay it's okay process is
almost complete What?
There we go.
See it?
Easy.
So easy.
No damage run.
It stopped.
Finally stopped.
Thank God.
Alright, back up top.
Get almost processed.
Alright.
Oh wait.
Wait, it's the other...
Wait, what's on the other side?
Oh, it's...
Oh, wait.
That's...
It's a processing machine.
Wasn't even worried.
That really...
This really is a perfect stream game for you.
Leon section shows off your shooting skill.
Great shows how entertaining you are when you're scared.
Thank you for the super chat, Lolly.
Thank you.
I'm not scared, guys.
I'm so brave.
I'm just being very I'm just playing for my life
called um it's called playing for your life I'm acting I'm
just acting guys I'm just reacting yeah I'm just playing it
up for the Oh, yeah, of course, of course, obviously.
I'm going to get across.
What the fuck?
Oh, here.
I'll go in the vent.
I'm venting.
Okay, here.
And then through that vent.
Wait, do I have enough?
And then I got to...
Go this way, okay.
God, my flashlight is so ass.
Oh my god, what the fuck is that?
What is that?
Oh, it's just blood.
Okay, that's okay.
Oh shit, maybe it's not okay.
Just some blood, you know?
Nothing to be worried about.
It's okay.
The virus is only transmitted through bites.
It's through the saliva.
A little blood in the mouth won't hurt me.
Just a little fun bloodslide.
Yeah, wee!
I'm collecting it.
Oh, my God.
Look at all that free blood.
There's so much blood, but I can't do anything.
Blood for the blood god, exactly.
Oh, wait.
I've lost scrap.
I can make more...
Injectors.
Oh, I should combine these.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
Now I can use this.
Alright.
Slurp that blood up, Grace.
Crimson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, too bad you didn't pre-order the Super Deluxe Dupre
Edition.
It comes with six hours of Leon content and a cami suit for
Grace.
Allow her to perform.
arrow into zombies in all seriousness thank you for being
awesome thank you super chat thank you what who's that above
me can't be the guy left for dead right that's definitely
not gonna turn into a blister head yeah i have so many
injections i don't try i'm no one wasted though it's for
emergencies only See look He's still
Hmm Hmm
Maybe he decomposed guys He He decomposed Okay the rats got
him The rats ate up the body chat He's The rest.
Where?
Question.
Where did that come from?
Where did it?
No way.
Where did that come from?
Um.
Must have been the win.
Got it.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Okay, it's fine.
I'll just use it all up.
Oh, it's the rat.
Look.
Look, look.
You found the rat.
Yeah.
it's okay oh it's danger it's no longer okay look see fine
it's okay she's blind
she's blind she's blind
look she found the rat
also like where the fuck was he I swear to God, like, wait,
what did he show up?
Nah, he's not going to turn.
Am I?
Whoa!
It's okay, I got the tunnel.
I got the tunnel.
She's not going to chase me in the tunnel.
She's too short, and she's too tall.
It's alright.
Just know how to turn left and right.
See it?
That easy.
Zero survival instincts.
I ran straight at her.
See, she got so confused.
Chat, chat, it's a strategy.
Because everyone will expect you to run left and to run
back.
But she was so confused because I ran forward.
Like, she didn't know what to do.
Guys.
She's like, what the fuck?
She ran in front of me?
It's a strat.
Okay, wouldn't it be easier if I just threw him up?
I swear to God, I have to carry her.
If it works, it works.
We never expect it.
Where's the courts, Emily?
Where's the courts?
Before I carry you, where's the courts?
Where did you put it?
Where?
Oh my God, I do have to lift it.
Emily, can you...
She cannot.
Why is it so loud?
It's gonna be okay.
Just don't let go.
Where am I going?
Wait, where is the...
Okay, it's that way.
Okay, I was like, where is the elevator?
All right, it's five.
The elevator is just right in front of me.
True.
See, look at that.
It's that easy.
Now...
Just beating you down.
Now you're not getting hit.
Got them jokes.
Oh my god.
I just killed...
It's not okay.
It's okay.
Now.
See?
It's okay.
I told you.
Everything is okay.
Toki, you forgot a permanent upgrade statement.
I had to carry a blind.
Do you want me this old?
You're like, Toki, you would never save a blind orphan.
And now you're like, Toki, why didn't you grab the
statement?
Either I leave her to die or I get an upgrade.
I...
gotta pick a lane here i'm oh i can only do one thing at a
time
oh what's going on
always upgrade w doki didn't abandon the child
How the fuck did DSP not see that?
How the fuck did not see the giant press F key?
Leave the chat.
Let's play.
Five, little girl.
It's okay, she can grow the eye.
We're fine.
See?
Look at that.
We still have our legs.
I knew we still have our legs.
I can't believe, like, I couldn't throw my Molotov.
I saved that Molotov for the great escape.
I was like, oh my god, guys.
I can see it.
They're all going to run in.
I have my Molotov, and then they're going to run in.
I was planning it in my head.
It's going to look so fucking cool.
And then I had to pick up the goddamn blind child.
I...
Here, I...
I kept this safe for you.
I was so ready.
I was like, it's going to look so fucking cool.
Oh my god, the courts.
Thank God.
She could have given me this earlier, but thank God.
see we're okay let's go
oh my god oh shit I didn't see you can bring over up more
okay I'll bring me over up I didn't even see that you guys I
don't know the dialogue was you guys could hear about bring
up the overall volume up a little all right i brought it up
a little bit more oh my god can i i can't leave you there's
no couches there's no fucking couches there this doesn't
matter apparently until like new game plus leave with me
it's not safe here um okay oh my god where do i go where the
do okay
okay oh we have to go this way it's all right leon like i
use leon to to clean up the place a little so it should be
okay oh i don't okay that's fine we just gotta this is not
this is not the right okay it's right here the floor is lava
apparently she doesn't like it when her bare feet touches
the floor like she's like i have to stand up for several
seconds um no thank you i want to save
relay the floor is cold turkey um i don't want to sit on the
dirty ass uh porcelain floor i the lord killed her parents
turkey have you no heart okay let's grab the two keys and
then um grab the requiem gun real quick i need to grab some
stuff that leon helped me clean up Okay, corn cabinet.
No, it's fine.
Oh, the guy...
The guy's gone.
Where did he go?
Alright, apparently you can grab an extra key here.
By doing...
Seven!
Boom!
Lucky number seven!
Let's go!
Let's Let's
Never mind
It was no longer lucky number Wait where do I Where is the
Okay this is here right Oh yeah there's the bathrooms where
you flush Eight times
See it's back Here up Top.
I need to grab the pistol.
Can let it ride.
Okay, well, it doesn't fucking matter anymore.
Like...
It's fine.
I need to grab her other gun.
That I...
That's right!
Bam!
Get out of here!
Look, you can see the blood spot of all, like, every time
I've shot the knee.
Wait, where?
Okay, the stairs are up here.
I have to go upstairs.
And then...
Alright, there's the coins.
There we go.
Yay!
Leon did that.
She did that for me!
Okay.
And there was a gun here.
Tanya's pistol in the world.
Oh, it's my self-defense.
Oh, my God.
I still can't believe the director didn't, like, the
director just gave me a bunch of papers and was go to a
crime scene, like, where brutal murders were committed.
Like, and
all I got was this tiny-ass gun that I bought with my first
paycheck.
Oh, that is so sad.
sad why the fuck would i use this gun with no backup
get out of here oh he's dead oh nice all right that's the
last i'll ever see of him
i will just go home
oh he should be fired at that point oh Nice.
Nice.
Now I got a big knife.
I don't even know which one's the big gun.
They're all pretty shit.
They're all pretty tiny.
All right.
Kick!
Pretty knife.
All right, let's get Emily out of here.
Emily!
All right, Emily, get over here.
All right.
We're going to leave now.
We did it.
Sayonara.
I peaked the basement level.
I've fucking made it out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's a coin.
Wait, I could gamble.
Wait, I can gamble one more time.
I forgot the upgrade.
I just realized.
I saw, I was like, wait, that's a coin.
All right, Emily, sit back on the couch.
Mama's gonna Gamba.
Finally, out of the basement.
It was here, right?
No, Gamba was here.
Oh, was there stats?
Oh, there is.
Power.
Can't even tell.
Why the fuck?
What the scundas ass?
it has every stat is worse
wait is that that's oh my god no that was the gun i started
with that was the gun i fucking found okay it's a straight
upgrade all right okay never mind the one i'm looking
holding was is grace's gun
all right seven
15.
Cover all my bases.
There we go.
Lucky number 7.
29 or 15.
Let it.
That 22?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's 29.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where's my coin?
I was promised a coin.
can i only bet one oh my god i can only i can only bet one i
can only bet one i didn't even realize that i thought i
could like put all my all all the coins on all the numbers
all right where's my money hello oh there it is yay okay
they were like just checking it have I cheated?
They're like, um, I didn't.
I, it was my lucky number.
29 is my lucky number.
I would never cheat.
The game was like, how does she know?
Is she a data farm it?
All right.
Steroids.
Extremism, increased mask health.
There we go.
Nice.
How did she know?
They were checking my ID, making sure I'm above 18.
I almost...
Can I just leave without it?
Yeah, 729-15th day, umbrella court was copied.
I can't leave it.
I'm leaving it.
Oh my God, she can walk on her own.
I still
can't believe the final puzzle.
They just like...
It's just not as fun anymore when they just like...
of actually coming in as a community to figure out the
solution because the first two days before like people were
solving the final solution i i thought it was so cool that
everyone was working to yeah the data miners yeah data mine
everyone's working to that i mean like oh my god how like we
could look at it could be this it could be that the toilet
oh yeah and toilet gate everyone's like the toilets guys the
toilet why would they let us flush the toilets unless that's
part of the code and everyone was like you're crazy you got
your crazy old man the toilet has nothing to do with it
they're like the toilets guys and a toilet gate was they
called it toilet gate and they're like toilet gate is real
what does it mean they're like guys they want us to flush
the toilet surely it has something to do with the bottom
puzzle because like to be fair like I'm like when you hear
that that sounds fucking crazy it does it just be like No,
fuck, you're just crazy, old man.
But then they were right.
They were fucking right.
Yeah, they sucked the fun out of a funny, like a silly
Easter hunt.
It was all connected.
Finally.
Hey, we're on the other side.
We made it.
Yay.
We did it.
Emily.
Emily?
You were right.
We made it.
out we did it for leon i can't wait to play 15 minutes of
leon guys where the do i go we need to keep moving okay
emily oh she's sleepy the courtyard okay i was gonna say
toilet gate was real always believed in the toilets We were
like, there's no way there's a secret code.
Hey.
Oh, the pilot.
Stay right there.
Hey, it's okay.
We're not infected.
So you're normal?
He's just out getting a smoke break while all this shit was
happening.
Those things.
Does he even have a gun?
What has he been doing?
I don't even worry about me.
I'm tired.
The toilet conspiracy confirmed.
That's okay.
Oh, what?
Uh, this?
Oh, uh, old war wound.
I can't run away even if I wanted to.
Can you fly this?
Short cannon.
My bastard blast.
What do you mean?
I'm still...
there's more what do you mean i was wasting my bullets
because i thought it was over that's why i was like shooting
everything what do you mean it's in there wait it's in where
i'd go myself it's it's it's in another what what do you
what are you wrong to me have you seen the same shit i've
seen look lady we're out of options here how much more do
you think any of us can i go back I thought, it's Doki's
time to carry this guy.
I'll protect her.
If you get the key.
Do it for Leon Doki.
Also, sound guy.
I don't know if you're still here, but is it better now?
It's a deal.
I caught you.
Pastor Kee's actions on you.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Don't need my bullets.
Ha, ha, go gamba.
Pew, pew, pew.
I was like, Sayonara to this shitty place.
Gotta play my cool-ass Leon now.
Just to find out I'm still on grace.
I'll be right back.
Goodbye, losers!
It's Lehigh time!
The game's like, oh, silly naive toky.
It's never over.
Silly toky, you thought you were free.
I was so silly, guys.
I truly was...
was so silly.
You thought I could never leave that building.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, where am I?
Okay, it's not so bad.
It's just one house.
project review of victor your grace period has been extended
thank you for the super chat peter thank you thank you wait
what was laggy i'm okay now i think it was the cut scene
dokey once she gets the keys just for the game to go random
bullshit go or i think of the super chat thank you thank you
uh patience preliminary research findings It was just a
cutscene.
Oh my god, where the fuck am I?
Wait, there's...
Oh, no item 5.
Alright, do I need to take anything?
Nah, it should be good.
Please, just let it be in here.
Oh, it's never just in there, is it?
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, hey, it's like...
That looks like from another Resident Evil game.
Oh, there's something...
Oh, he's going to carry a bone saw, isn't he?
Oh, he's going to carry a bone saw.
He's going to come in here.
The center was found.
Can I actually break that?
I'm going to break it.
I can't.
Glass is bulletproof.
I should be able to break this and use this against him.
Cardiac meds.
and yeah
your presentation was quite impressive while we were pleased
to hear that the experiment has progressed to phase four is
far from the results we expected it has been more than 20
years since the establishment of this care center we require
clear results as an added precaution we have requested that
blockade be extended 2040 it's imperative we obtain elfis
before that deadline all right oh hey this is the the moon,
whatever.
Take this off.
I want to see the code.
Oh, it's right here, guys.
There's the code.
Let me I can, like, take something off from here?
I don't think so.
How am I going to do a fucking
hourglass?
I didn't take anything from it.
Boobs.
Never.
It's never boobs, guys.
Oh, here it is.
A little Russian doll.
And then if you open it inside, it's going to be a smaller
wine bottle.
Oh, it's DNA.
Never mind.
It's DNA.
Yeah.
Am I supposed to do a DNA?
Whoa.
I think I should be able to...
Clearly says boob zonky.
Fuck am I supposed to do that with it?
On both, which seems like they can slot into...
Yeah, it won't let me combine it, though.
I could combine it or some shit.
Who switched up my wine with DNA?
Is that table in the middle?
Oh, is that another wine bottle?
Another DNA bottle?
Oh, I didn't even see that little...
Okay, I didn't see this.
Oh, cool.
Oh.
Put my DNA in.
Oh, it's an elevator.
Oh.
It's a secret lab.
It was never just a room.
it was never just one house was it dragons it's it's never
just one tiny house it's the resident evil laboratory
there's always a secret lab in resident evil there's always
a secret lab
It's Resident Evil 101.
At least there's a typewriter.
It's never just the room.
The basement, part two.
Electric Boogaloo.
Alright.
A classic.
Alright, I just wanted to see if Sound Guy said anything
earlier.
Alright, I think Sound Guy disappeared.
Alright.
the pilot i'll set up i'll set up by the pilot he knew he
knew there was a secret lab it wouldn't just be right there
in the house humanity suffers when the drive and experience
of our most exceptional leaders is lost the ultimate way to
preserve such greatness they got him yeah is to transfer
those memories to a new vessel just as fruit flies have the
potential to pass on too, can the memories of a human donor
be passed on to a recipient?
The question we now face is how to harness this incredible
potential.
The answer lies in the medium memory, blood.
Cells within the blood contains multitudes of information,
including factors tied to memory.
Thus, since the TIR virus grants us control over factors
within the blood, it can be hypothesized that harnessing
those same elements will allow us to transfer memories from
superior individuals.
Oh my gosh, the memories are stored in the blood.
However, for such a procedure to succeed, the host must be
able to withstand the toxicity of the mutated T-virus strain
while preserving their own intelligence.
Sourcing viable subjects will be the key to future research
and testing.
Also, by the way, I just found out apparently every game of
Resident Evil contradicts each other.
So every game is canon, yet every game of Resident Evil just
doesn't make sense if you link them all together.
as long as it looks cool though guys it doesn't matter if
nothing makes sense as long as it looks absolutely cool and
sick okay
oh these are the memories the memories are stored in the
buzz The rules of cool.
Something's being shot.
The blood.
What's the blood?
What the blood got?
Can't bed injector.
I need that.
Oh, they're all gonna start coming alive, aren't they?
Alright, there's the map.
Map time.
Alright.
There's the emergency route that It's too heavy to, oh, oh
my god, Grace, when is something not too heavy?
What, okay, Miss Noodle Arms, Gordon, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you.
They have to be paying construction companies billions to
make this many secret labs.
Does Ocea know about this?
They're in the super chat, Gordon, thank you, thank you.
They're like, hmm, this company sure loves making me mix.
All these secret laboratories with all these puzzles.
Like, hey.
Marsha, we got another order for 80 hallways and 20
elaborate puzzles in this mansion.
Quite weird that they keep making us make puzzles.
If I can carry a small blind child, I can open a door.
Nothing suspicious.
here.
Here are the results of the comprehensive blood analysis you
requested.
The genetic information matches the specific data perfectly.
Oh, see?
Yeah, that's the code.
Or the puzzle.
Alright, helicopter key.
I finally got it.
Door locks activated.
Alright, unlock that door.
It's not Big talk from someone new to arm's I can still open
doors
At least I can open a door Like oh I can open this door
Apparently like this door is fine Victor Who the fuck is
Victor Oh Oh him I'm special That's me all goes as planned
help us will soon be in our hands of course the first i must
initiate sorry it's been so long since i saw i've been
trapped in the basement for so long guys i've lost track it
felt like 20 years in that basement
i've done it a scientific breakthrough
I still can't believe they hired this man.
His eyes were literally black.
Surely this evil looking guy couldn't be evil.
Oh my god, a fucking curse.
Hey Marshall, it's weird that they wanted us to fill in a
self-destruct protocol.
Do you think we're working for an evil man?
That's pretty weird.
Wait, where is the room?
Oh no.
Truly, truly this company can't be evil.
Why else would they want us to make it?
Oh my god, I'm lost.
I got lost.
I got lost in the sauce.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's fake.
That's... This is it.
I've been waiting.
for this moment this is it I've been waiting for this day oh
my god I'm a genius okay okay they all have to there we go
boom Oh my god, I did it.
This was it.
This was my day.
Oh shit!
It's okay.
Threat the needle!
Alright, see?
Perfect.
Don't get that.
so clean oh oh where am i oh guys i am oh my god it's okay
it's okay it's okay i know where to go oh it is absolutely
okay it is everything will be oh don't worry grace Just keep
running.
Just keep running.
Okay, see?
I told you guys.
Everything will be...
Oh!
Get up!
Grace!
See?
Everything is just a little bit of blood.
Oh, won't hurt anybody.
We're so...
We are so safe.
Look at that.
nothing to worry about.
We got the helicopter key.
Why does this shit keep happening?
The iron line.
Wow.
Mercupil, his iron line was pretty good.
Molo, thank you with magenta soup.
I'm so healthy, guys.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
It's like a reverse water slide.
better because it's blood.
At worst, Leon.
Claire is running out of time.
They're going to jet this.
Holy shit.
Where the fuck did he come from?
Okay, I do not like that there is a smash glass window
there.
I do not recall this window being smashed.
Can't believe evil stole from Markiplier.
Wow, it's the building's time of the month.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, nothing's wrong.
We are so safe, little girl.
I'm right next to you.
No, lady.
I'm gonna need you up front.
No, it's okay.
I'm alright.
Yeah, he's like, yes, please leave.
Oh, there are so many of them.
Strap in.
Why is she so clean now?
She was wearing those like waterproof shirts.
Oh, that is not good.
She ran so fast that the blood disintegrated, guys.
She broke the sound barrier and the blood ripped off from
her shirt.
Oh, that is not good.
As long as he doesn't get bit, he's fine, guys.
He's totally fine.
See?
Oh!
That's not good.
Oh, no.
What do you mean?
I'm not free.
Oh,
she's fine.
Oh, guys, he didn't get bit though.
God, he didn't get bit.
It's just the flesh.
That tree missed all the internal organs, and he didn't get
bit, so he should be fine.
Oh my God, thank God.
I cannot, guys, oh my God, I did it.
I did it for Leon.
I fucking did it.
I made it.
I, I, I, I just gotta put some herb on it.
I gotta spray a little bit of the herb spray.
I like how the story is like going at the same time, too.
He's so cool.
Oh my god.
God.
I wish I was just as cool as him.
Guys, I got rewarded with 15 minutes of leon oh
shit that girl just can't stay out of trouble
what am i supposed to be looking at where did he where did
he look at oh i'm oh whoops sorry sherry grace is still here
the fbi agent i was like how can i not see it from all the
way here when you could see it during the cutscene it'll be
fine exactly
oh no that's hair wait what happens if I
don't worry I got it I'm a hero
there you
I'm like, what?
That was on his head.
Got reloaded, though.
Should be fine now.
Yeah, she's past the point.
All right, where is she?
Okay, I have to shoot.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
shit she's fine see what are you scared oh okay that's on
the head you can't tell me that was not on the head there
you go all right though go ahead reload oh shit sorry oh
it's okay she'll be fine
There was ammo in front of me.
Hey, I got distracted by the ammo.
Can you really blame me?
It was loot.
Wait, there's extra zoom?
Oh my god, there's extra zoom.
Does she know?
Gamers don't look down.
Oh, shit.
shiny.
I mean, who would be jealous of how he's handling that
rifle?
I hear them.
Oh, there he is.
Toki.
What's your sexuality?
Leon.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Didn't want to shot his ass.
I got distracted.
Oh, shit.
I got...
It's okay, Emily's alive!
Emily, crawl!
Crawl, Emily!
Crawl!
Sorry, too busy looking at Leon.
I'm sorry, Grace.
It's...
Alright, look, this time, I grabbed the ammo first.
I was not paying attention to the lack of ammo.
ammo I had.
What?
Where did he come from?
Someone got very distracted.
Where did the awk come from?
I don't remember.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shit.
I did it again.
Oh, shit, Lehigh.
Okay.
I did it again.
Okay, it's okay.
reloaded this time.
Everything is fine.
At this time, I reloaded.
I don't need different vantage point.
I just need one.
One point.
One shot.
One kill.
Okay, now I pre-reload this time.
What do you mean it's not limited ammo?
Reload?
What's that?
I just shoot gun, and then my gun reloads for me.
That's a loud sound.
Oh, there he is.
I gotta make sure he doesn't show up.
Okay, that should have hit him.
Okay, that is bad.
I'm running out of ammo.
There we go.
See, everything is fine.
Stop gooning to Leon and save Grace.
Thank you for the super chat, Mr. Brokip.
She's fine.
She's so healthy.
Nothing's bad ever happened to her.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Oh, my God.
He's so cool.
Excuse me.
Thank you for breaking my landing there.
You're wrong.
That's right.
You don't even...
Oh shit, never mind!
Hell yeah, sit!
You don't even need a use not your gun, Leon.
Boom!
You know what?
Give me that ammo.
That's right.
Boom!
Wait, are you still alive?
That's red.
Oh, shit.
That's fucking red.
Give me that shit.
Let's sharpen my knife now.
Monster hunting.
He's so badass.
God, Japan's national treasure.
Grace.
Where she?
Oh, this is Emily.
Help me.
I can't stop the blue.
hey hey look at me we're gonna be okay yeah okay you're
gonna be okay but what about the child can't stay here that
should be the way to the water treatment place your cooney
is putting grace and emily in danger please on the card
thank you for chatting thank you thank you i just don't give
This was worth it.
The basement level was worth it.
Oh, shit.
The boobs are pulsating.
I don't think that's how boobs are supposed to work.
If your boobs are pulsating, that's bad.
What the fuck?
I'm supposed to kill you, right?
There we go.
Alright, I go up now.
girl girl there we go yeah oh not yet oh shit wait wait a
minute that's not very yay I'm fine oh
shit I'm oh shit it's running it's not supposed to do that
Oh
fuck okay
You know what fuck this There you go There we go now it
should be it that's the last move You know what the one guy
I Think it's not good Not the rest?
Who's still alive?
Time to clean out the rest.
Oh, okay.
The game was like, wait a minute.
Did you see that dorky never said that?
The one guy is trying so hard.
The rest.
yeah i mean they gave me three bombs i think that's a little
overkill no what do you mean that's it that's it no i should
have a saver in the leon oh my there's got to be a way to
get to the surface
i stood up sort of savored the Leon.
I did it too fast.
If I knew, if I knew that that was all I had was, I thought
I had more.
I, if I, I would have, I would have, I would have tried to
enjoy it more.
I would have, I would savored the Leon moment.
Leon moment over, but like come back great.
That's like, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, oh my god, he's so
good, can I have some more?
And the game was like, that's it.
That was all the Leon.
It was like, what?
It just went slow and steady.
That was the last Leon.
Please make sure to leave a review and give us five stars.
Leave a comment and a review For your Leon enjoyment.
Oh My god, can't even fucking turn on a flashlight I'm
sorry, I know it hurts I'm so sorry
How how how there's no couches for her how there's no
couches in the fucking sewers how because she refused to sit
on the floor did she she refused to sit on the floor even
when she's dying
oh my god can't let that thing hurt her it's okay emily here
rest here here you go I need to keep you safe okay she is
losing a lot of blood though all right meds the roof has
just operated by panel outside I still can't believe it it
was just it was it wasn't even I was promised 15 minutes of
Leon I should have dragged the 15 minutes longer the worst
part is like if i did if i actually didn't die there it
would have been even less time on leon if i didn't get
distracted by how cool he was i you must restart the three
power distributors distribution units and that was too good
time goes so fast when you're having fun all right all right
get rid of the tiny gun we don't need the tiny gun this is
the what bad gun right okay we'll store that we'll bring in
more handgun more apparently that is for the requiem bullets
um we have well we have five requiem bullets now okay can i
actually make it now no i can't all right so i put the rare
metals back
yeah it'll be too exciting guys y'all pace yourself we get
too much leon the world is not ready for it the world is
simply not ready for all this leon did i say i can i thought
i couldn't i clicked on it enough to craft it yet?
Crafting?
No, I can only craft a handgun.
I'm not smart enough, apparently.
Wait, that's the rare metal.
Now I don't have the recipe.
I missed the magnum gun.
Oh, apparently I did.
Apparently I did.
It's okay.
We won't need it.
I have two bullets and a dream.
That two minute will come in clutch, guys.
Those two bullets?
Insufficient power.
Reset the power distribution units on the lower floor.
Gotta get the power room.
It's my only chance.
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
Alright, here we go.
It's okay, there's no fall damage.
I mean, I should leak.
It's okay, there was no fall damage.
Had to be true.
ammo oh look see three bullets three bullets and a dream
please tell me she's not right behind me isn't she is she
right behind me that's right that's right get away What you
gotta do now?
That's right.
Oh, no.
I don't know where to go.
She can't fist through this door.
She's too big.
She's too thick for that.
anything I know I don't have a key what the fuck do I go
okay are you gonna run I don't know there has to be one
somewhere okay look
I thought I was I I don't know I just thought she'll she'll
run away I didn't realize I had to run away I
okay a crank lover what the fuck is the crank lover for
what okay okay it's okay it's okay it's a cutscene it's um
it's a cutscene it's a cutscene
it's okay it's part of the cutscene it's okay it's part of
the no no that's not part of the cutscene
okay apparently that wasn't oh my god oh my okay okay on the
way from the beginning let's go all right let's let's try
this again no head that is technically I was like, it's
scripted.
It's okay, guys.
It's scripted.
It's okay.
I don't need to do the inventory stuff.
It saved.
Okay, I got five bullets.
Five bullets and a dream.
I don't need no recipe.
Wait, what's that crank for?
That crank was for that thing, right?
The main room area thing?
Gotta get the power room.
It's my only chance.
Just wanted me to share.
Yeah?
Okay, she just threw...
Okay, so she was just throwing me away from it.
I got a little confused.
So she was just throwing me away from the crank.
Crank that soldier, boy.
No longer crank that soldier boy.
I ran the wrong way.
Oh, she can't come in here.
There's a leg.
I missed?
Jesus.
I...
It's okay.
look look she's so fishy look the gun was the recoil was
crazy okay the gun recoil was insane like it's the recoil
guys it's the weak arms threw me off her weak arms threw me
off guys There, see?
See, I got it now.
Now that I...
Now that I calculated the recoil...
Create that soldier boy.
Grace.
Look, guys.
I had to calculate the recoil and the bounce off.
And...
And the force...
It could have happened to anyone.
What the f-
True.
Where do I go?
I'm trying to figure that.
Okay.
Oh wait, it is back there.
Jesus Christ, okay.
It was like frustrating to...
That's not gonna be right, bro!
That's run!
That's right, run!
Oh.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh no, sorry!
No!
Okay.
I should have ran.
I shouldn't grab.
No, you gotta be...
Okay, okay, okay.
Now that I know...
Okay, guys, I purposely died there.
So...
I purposely died there so I could keep my bullet.
You remember?
Remember how I wasted that app?
That bullet?
So I purposely died there so I wouldn't waste all the ammo
back guys oh my god do i have to like do the thing at first
and then oh my god i do
yeah yeah see so it i it was on purpose i died on purpose so
i i swear to do is it one hit one kill Or is it because I
was cautioned?
Look at that.
See, I learned my lesson.
See, guys?
Jesus.
Look at them juke!
Oh, now you stealth dokey.
Look, see, I can...
See, guys?
I can learn.
Third time's the charm.
Okay, it's bullshit that, like, you have to start all the
way back, though.
What the fuck?
Stevek.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm freaking out.
I'm back.
Okay, crack that.
Okay.
Leave.
That's right.
Run.
Two to go.
Okay.
Okay, now I gotta figure this out.
I'm very stealthy.
He's gonna jump.
Stop crouching.
Stop crouching, Grace.
That's right.
That's not right.
That is not right.
Careful.
Oh, careful.
She doesn't know.
Crank that.
Why did I turn off the legs?
Come on.
What do you mean?
It's okay.
I have time.
I have...
No!
I no longer have time.
I no longer have the time.
It's okay.
She's gonna come up and then that's right get over here girl
That's right.
I know you want to.
Oh, I'm so vulnerable Standing here in the she's camping me
isn't she she's standing here in the corner Oh Oh, no, what
oh, I mean, okay
Okay, she just walked.
I mean, that's fine.
That works, too.
Now I can do this nice and slow.
There we go.
I knew saving all those bullets was a good idea.
All right, let's see.
It says five, so it should be five.
Okay, I got more.
Oh, it's so far.
Only one more.
Oh, God, that is so far.
That one more is like in Nanya.
I'm doing my own pilgrimage.
To the promised land.
I don't like this.
I loot.
One more bullet for the ride.
Wait, that's a dead end.
Oh my god, it's back here.
Where is he?
That's right!
That's right.
Bam!
Big but Leon.
That's where all the lights are on now.
What you gonna do here?
Wait, how do I get out though?
I need a hurt.
Wait, how do I?
How do I get out?
Alright, back here.
See you guys, I don't need no recipe.
I had just enough.
I told you.
We're getting out of here.
Get out of the fucking way.
I lost track of where the button was.
I...
Come on.
Hold on.
Yay!
Boom!
That's right.
I...
Oh.
Leon might have given me one bullet, but I had a dream.
That's fucking right.
No recipe needed.
I told you guys.
The hoarding works.
I fucking did it.
I didn't waste my bullets on those stupid zombies.
one shot one kill that's what he meant
that's alright she can't revive until it's nighttime why did
you kill a child um it was a murderous child it was a child
murder oh well now I killed two kids now I'm the child
murderer oh no wake up come on in game in game in Resident
Evil I mean she needs a blood transfusion
killed streak
Wake up, Emily!
Uh-uh, uh-uh, stay alive, stay alive.
Uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh, stay alive, stay alive.
Uh-uh, uh-uh.
I'm just helping her with the chest compressions.
With the CPR.
Yeah, doing the rhythm of staying alive.
That is true.
I feel like CPR is really bad.
against an open wound, isn't it?
You're literally pumping the blood out of her.
No.
Oh.
Oh, she's alive.
It worked.
I'm right here.
You're okay.
Oh my
god.
She's turning.
Shoot her.
Grace.
You.
Who didn't care when you shot her sister?
Oh.
I'm like uncomfortable with this monster.
Oh shit Leon!
I'm sorry.
Doesn't matter.
Akhil is Akhil.
Do it.
Kill, streak save.
For all the escort missions.
Leon's here, kill, steal.
You don't understand.
No, I never would have escaped without her.
You just know.
This is all my fault.
Again.
We gotta get it.
Trust me, I get it.
But we're still alive.
We have to keep going.
Quick, somebody.
Get her a sofa.
Grace, you fucking idiot.
You're free now.
Grace.
What do you mean, Doki is so fucking...
That was...
She was gonna kill us.
That was a monster.
That wasn't Emily no more.
Oh, shit.
Oh no My blood cancer That's okay You're immune, Leon
They'll never kill you off You're Japan's national treasure
You literally sold 5 million units In less than a week They
could never kill you off They need to sell 5 million more
It was literally self-defense Oh yeah, the molds got her
Oh is within reach grace
well come with you come with him after everything he's done
grace don't be fucking stupid man you're exactly where you
need to be and then they're gonna clone leon and then it's
gonna be like metal gear and then and it's gonna be metal
gear solid where they just keep cloning snake wesker wait is
that wesker
for you unknown man no he's not british who are you american
wesker they made it a they cloned an american wesker you're
the reason for its destruction but you're also the key to
building a brave they're like he could be perfect and then
they made him they made an american wesker
let us show you your true purpose
This is my Walmart Wesker.
What do you mean?
Walmart Wesker versus, uh, what are some British, what are
the, what are the British chains?
Spence, Mark and Spencer.
Mark and Spencer Wesker versus Walmart Wesker.
They're gonna make a Wesker for every, for every region.
For every country.
Next we're gonna have Chinese Wesker.
Chinese Wesker, Japanese Wesker, German Wesker, British
Wesker, American Wesker.
Get ready for out.
Yay!
Leon!
The Wesker Multiverse.
Canadian Wesker.
Twitchy, they give the super chat thank you.
I was like, Wesker!
And then his accent was American.
and he's like, American Wesker!
But to be fair, he has these blonde, slick back hair and
black sunglasses.
That's Wesker-coated.
He's also so cool.
Five seconds.
What was it?
One minute.
That's all I need.
No.
Wesker's British.
Oh, she got the mold.
Sherry, it's okay.
It's okay.
Ethan was okay until he got nuked.
But it's okay.
Did you find anything on Elpis?
Oh, no.
Not yet.
Nothing on the servers of the CIA or the Pentagon.
Maybe we need a higher clearance.
The black mold got her.
I requested one.
And I was told to shut down the investigation.
French whisker.
Papa's smart.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just cut off the head.
Exactly.
For this.
I'll just go it alone.
We're in this together.
Till the end.
I've always been good at working in the shadows.
Just don't do anything too risky, yeah?
Me?
Never.
I'm going to find Grace.
She definitely has something to do with Elpis.
What the fuck is Elpis?
So we haven't figured it out yet.
Back to where it all began.
To the...
Raccoon City!
Oh my god.
We're going back.
To your origin, evacuate immediately.
Now that paper lived through a nuclear bomb?
Come home.
It's like Silent Hill.
All the road's gone.
Can't find his way.
We'll have to find another way around.
All right.
I think I found a clue as to where they might be.
Some coordinates on Victor's computer.
Got it, thanks.
right in the center of raccoon city All right the center
Then you got wrecked like nothing makes sense in resident
evil story Every game is connected to each other but yet
every game somehow contradicts each other evacuate
immediately If you are in raccoon city, I urge you to
evacuate now Leave if you can if you cannot evacuate go to
the police station the nearest public facility Wherever you
can.
Take any weapon you have and hide in the nearest sturdy
building.
This will probably be the last paper we've published.
And I am the last Raccoon Times reporter.
Thank you, dear readers, for all your support over the
years.
I urge you once more.
Run, find something.
Yeah, I was going to say, that is a shitty-ass nuke.
And we still can find...
And, like, this is all...
Also, why can't I not drive my Porsche a little closer?
Like...
There is an empty road in front of you, Leon.
then who printed the last reporter he is the last reporter
he printed it himself he did it all i'm pretty sure by the
time he finished printing the the bomb dropped just a really
big bomb
oh nice i got back my gun yeah now it's nothing but ash and
memory oh shit i can't craft i just I won't be able to craft
more bullets.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I did not care about Grace, but I realized I should have
got more.
Oh, I should have got the recipe for Leon.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that was it.
Oh, that might have been an oversight.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
thank you thank you oh he has his own oh thank god i was
gonna say that's very unfortunate that i don't have a recipe
for his his gun that's true i got his axe though
that's a lot of are those spider webs what is that that's a
lot of spider-man team over here
Okay, for parries, can I just hold it and it'll parry, or
does it have to be a perfect parry?
Oh, guys.
Remember I said I had something...
Panamom?
He's coming!
It's solid, the tank engine!
They got him!
They...
I remember this, Buzz.
What do you mean?
He was always there.
He was in Resident Evil 2.
What do you mean?
This tradition.
It's...
I think...
I can't but thank God I'm guys thank God Thomas scared to
any spot it would have been thank you for the super chat
absolutely thank you thank you I just I said I changed one
thing in the game I oh shit oh shit oh shit choo choo choo
choo Oh my god.
Oh no, no!
Oh my god, he's gonna run me over.
He's gonna run me over, guys.
I gotta get out of here.
That's terrible.
Oh god, it's okay.
A door will stop Thomas.
Oh no.
all right it's okay i was gonna give it to you oh my god oh
my god he has babies he
oh god oh god there's so many of them
unfortunately did not have the music but i could just chop
why am i wasting my bullet oh he's gonna jump isn't he chop
oh shit i got the baby trains do I go this way oh shit do
not go that way do not go that way oh and this
oh god oh god oh god oh god
Give me a sec.
There we go.
It's fine.
I'm reloading.
Where is he?
Where's Thomas?
Oh my god, there he is.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's everywhere.
He's everywhere.
Where is he?
Guys, I'm doing it!
What's scarier than a spider?
A train.
Oh shit!
Holy fuck!
That was truly scarier than a spider.
That's true.
Where did he go?
Oh fuck, it's Thomas!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, it's okay.
It's okay.
God.
Gotta come down.
Okay, that's awkward.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
It's okay everything is fine.
Oh God.
How much speed does this train have?
Choo choo choo choo.
Oh my god there is no.
There's no fucking light in those eyes.
Here.
That's right.
Oh God.
Oh my god.
Okay, we jumped down.
That's right.
One.
Wait.
I just...
Wait, where do you go?
Bullet don't work on trains, dude.
I just gotta hit the fuel engine, guys.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
The babies are here.
The babies!
Oh my god, the babies!
Get the babies off of me!
The tiny trains!
I was not expecting the tiny trains yet.
Oh god.
Not the tiny trains.
Oh my god, he's still spinning on tiny trains!
He's still, he's still spitting on.
Okay, this is very awkward.
It's okay.
I got him.
I did not got him.
I did not.
He came back up.
Oh, God.
Trains.
He has so many trains inside of him.
Oh.
Choo-choo chow's all over again.
Lolly, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He wishes he was just as good as Thomas.
Oh my god, where is he?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he fucking...
It's okay.
Oh, it's no longer.
It is no longer okay.
It's okay.
Oh my god, where did I fall?
How much HP does he have?
Holy shit, he's climbing the walls.
He's in my walls.
Thomas.
Oh, no.
Not the babies.
Oh, my God.
not the baby oh my god that's it i want to ask you a
question
oh no oh no oh no get away from me get him it's not my stop
yet doesn't anyone taught you how to play nice there we go
is he dead he was not dead he is not dead
the normal has weak spots i don't think Oh no, he has a weak
spot.
Is that why it's taking me 20 years to kill Thomas?
I don't know where to shoot at.
I need to.
There you go.
I don't need to hit it.
I just got to ask you a question.
Here we go.
I did.
I came for the eyes.
Absolutely.
The Super Chat thank you, man.
I did
it.
It was worth it.
I
did it.
I killed a beloved...
We killed a beloved childhood train.
Thomas down.
all it took was all my ammo and all my heels
worth it 100% worth it never thought I'd see Thomas railing
Leon but here we are oh my god I killed him in the trains
too oh it's perfect I killed him in the train station
the perfect place to die it's so poetic
I was the only thing I wanted to mine in Resident Evil I
don't need ammo I got an axe look at that
looks like poor Thomas was derailed that's good
he joined his father and brethren he just i even killed his
the little kids too the little toy trains
all right out of the subway okay
sherry i've hit the barricade looks like someone else was
here first and they were planning on busting their way in
damn that's a lot of c4 no way around the army core of
engineer is erected it to seal the city it goes on for miles
I guess the only way in is through then all right examine
the gates the detonator is missing all right I find a
detonator it's like that way right is there anything this
way oh there was a lot of stuff I missed there
you think Thomas or who a whoever was here before yeah he
crushed him on the rails
it's fine I have enough ammo for this look at that found all
that ammo I fucking wasted on the train Thomas has no weak
points apparently the spotter did
the spotter might have weak points but there's no weak
points on a train.
Alright, someone said look up.
There's nothing here.
You lied.
I need a key for that.
Oh my god, look at that.
See?
I got rewarded.
Wasting all that ammo earlier.
Think about it.
It's not a waste now.
Sure, there's an old BSAA camp here.
The place is trashed.
Looks like they left in a hurry.
What were the BSAA doing in Raccoon City?
Interesting.
I'm gonna get water soon after this cutscene.
Computer's not locked.
They were also headed to the center of Raccoon City.
What are they doing?
Why are they heading to the center?
Pentagon's database and I noticed something's missing.
What's that?
of anyone ordering the missile strike on Raccoon City.
What's not done, then?
We aren't triggered the alarm.
Huh?
Looks like your campaign to make the DSO stand down really
didn't work, Zeno.
I'll leave this matter to you.
Why not end?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, is that?
Oh my god, upgraded.
No more type right.
for me let's go I'm gonna grab water real quick guys oh I'm
gonna whoops oh my god finally a laptop and so fucking
typewriter I'll be right back oh was that his name Zeno what
the fuck is Zeno American Wesker I'll be right back
also be right back I forgot to turn swap to air conditioning
because so hot in my room right now
oh yeah it's really hot in my room from all the Leon
cutscenes Yeah, especially when I beat up that train.
I was like, whoa, Leah, you're so cool.
You're in...
So cool seeing you beat up that train.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Let me see.
Give me a sec.
Doesn't need to get...
Cough drops, too.
I can't believe Thomas was evil all along the line.
Always has been.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Ever since Resident Evil came out, he's been haunting the
franchise.
He's always been evil.
What do you mean?
Whoops.
Give me a sec.
I just want to make sure my, for some reason, my live stream
thing froze, like the YouTube tab.
So I want to make sure I can see it.
All right, here we go.
Leon time.
Oh, nice.
Credits earned from kills can be used as supply box.
the more enemies you dispatch the more credits you earn
credits can be used to purchase oh wait now it counts it oh
wait i killed i killed a train that should be a hundred
thousand points okay it requires three parts also um mike
shady uh cyber wb papa meddy nexi solid thank you
we don't have much time avoid contact with the infected at
all costs if combat is unavoidable deal with it quickly
provide situational updates every 30 minutes all right
all right here we go i turn on the power so it should open
now right oh nice i was gonna say i turn on the power all
right there should be stuff here logistical warehouse okay
here are I'm here.
Alright, I have to be here.
I'm not scared.
You know how not scared I am?
When I'm him?
Where is it?
Where's the controller?
Where is... Run!
I'm always running.
Thank God.
That's right.
I don't need a walk.
I'm him.
all right gun powder can be used to craft a variety of ammo
is there anything else in here
yeah i'm getting my cardio in right now okay maybe maybe the
always run is not it okay it's not it i'm like bumping in
the walls i'm going too fast leon is too good at running
It's a little slippery here.
Yeah, it was a little awkward.
Okay, the stairs are broken.
Where are the zombies?
Yeah, where are the bodies?
That is suspicious.
There's no way the bomb got them on.
Hmm, it's a little sussy.
He's right.
It's quiet.
a little too quiet all I saw were spot oh maybe the spotters
got him but then if I oh oh
stupid wait wait wait a minute wait a minute I was like
get out of here get out of here why can't I What the fuck?
Oh, wait.
Made a attack.
Here we go.
I was gonna say...
Wait, he has...
Oh, shit!
Oh, perfect.
No, never mind.
Never mind.
I was gonna be like, Damn, right?
I got that, period.
You think I can...
Don't worry.
I got it.
There we go.
Bam!
I can't see anything.
Okay, we'll grab that.
Oh, oh, swing!
That's right.
Get out of here.
How the fuck did these guys live?
God, I shot through my axe.
God, oh God, I gotta get my ammo.
Wait.
wait a minute i don't like the sound of that okay i'm just
gonna shoot the head fuck this
like i can't for some reason it won't let me kneecap them
like i've been trying to kneecap them it's too much effort
these zombies are too strong they were molded into the sand
Come on, they're sad zombies.
They wouldn't let me knee- Yeah, they have very strong
knees, apparently.
That's fucking crazy.
Like, I couldn't- like, my strategy!
My knee strategy didn't work!
It's always worked!
Oh, fuck!
Alright, there you go.
I don't understand.
They don't miss leg day, apparently.
They did, in fact, tank a nuke.
There you go.
They did.
These are nuke zombies.
I was gonna say, like, what the fuck?
I literally shot that guy three times in a knee, and it
didn't give me the prompt.
usually it's like one shot to the knee and then a kick i'm
like i'm leon i'm motherfucking leon
what the what the oh god oh god that's bad that is bad
oh go easy okay this is bad only because i do not have a lot
of heals left oh never mind punished let's go oh Leon huh
you're never punished what what's that sound where could the
zombies be oh shit oh shit oh my god who who oh god I need a
sharpie my axe
There you go.
I'm like just far enough for him not to throw this.
Okay.
That's fine with me.
Are you still gonna walk?
Are you still gonna...
Alright.
Oh my god, this guy's...
This guy's head is so tanky.
Like his head is just all tumors or something.
some shit that's blocking all my bullets what
the fuck I was like there we go it's that and that all right
there's stuff here yeah he's very callous through some shit
his head was like trained for he got hit too many times in
the head it trained him for this moment he knew he was going
to turn into a zombie and fight for and fight for zombie
rights.
Alright, this way.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, woman.
Alright, I don't have to waste it.
Oh shit!
It's fine.
Just a little.
Jesus, these zombies are crazy buff.
God damn.
nuclear zombies.
Women.
Women jump scare.
Hmm.
Yeah, they should have.
You need new upgrades?
Oh, these are...
That's crazy.
I can't use my usual strat.
I just have to shoot the head and hope for the best.
They've been so hungry.
They're so...
hungry.
Alright, oh, here.
But those don't kill, yeah, they're like cockroaches.
They're moat.
They got the radiation buff.
How hungry.
Tell me I wish I could just drag this.
Instead of combining.
9,000.
What am I going to do with scrap?
Oh, handgun ammo.
I can create shotgun.
No, I don't need to create anything yet.
Oh my gosh.
Save shotgun for boss fights.
There should be a part.
Yeah, like literally when, because there's no nobody to eat,
they just hibernated in the sand.
Or in their little hibernation corner until fresh meat came
along.
So you guys, Will you give me a gun?
I'm unstoppable.
What's this?
Distributor.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Sherry, I found the distributor.
We did it.
Two more parts and I can jerry-rig the detonator for that
gate.
Great.
Can you see any more from your position?
One, two.
They were hiding from Thomas.
Yeah.
They heard Thomas, the tank engine.
They're like, oh no, we got hot in the sand.
Yeah.
All right.
That it?
There's a third one?
Oh shit, there is.
That should be a fun trip.
All right.
Got the location for those parts.
Going to collect them now.
I'll look into the PSAA in the meantime.
I thought I was supposed to like grab fuel for that.
place up top I guess not all right what did I earn what did
I get okay I got 18 kills nine thousand dollars all right oh
okay nine thousand case okay I don't need that body armor
maybe oh is it okay I don't need ammo I'm fine with ammo
guys what is the most ideal oh wait there's more Oh, I can
upgrade!
Wait, I can upgrade my gun?
A body armor is tempting, yeah.
Armor in case?
Is it really worth it?
I'll grab the armor first.
Okay, yeah, I think I'm gonna get body armor first.
I don't have enough HP for these tanky-ass zombies that did
not skip Arm Day.
Okay.
gas power generator supply box signal receiver how fuck do i
guess i go this way wait actually how the fuck do i get
there like wait a minute you're here block from the other
side
and maybe here oh i have the key there we go area oh hey oh
nice i need that actually oh five bullet wait i have five
bullets oh oh leon this is not so good no more i thought i
had ammo for days wait a minute what you mean my ammo for
days ended today that's not fair
are you here?
Oh, I can.
But what is over here?
Wait, where the fuck do I go first?
I could buy more ammo, yes, but I don't think I need to.
I'm going to reload everything.
Oh, I knew it.
I was like wondering which way.
I was like, one way is the loot.
The other way.
Oh, it's the ammo.
I reload my shotgun.
Make sure everything's loaded up.
Snapper ammo.
God, it's so dark.
Hello?
A pair of man's here.
Pizza time.
Oh, there he is.
Take a unsuspecting...
Ooh.
I don't know where he is, but I assume he's right in front
of me.
Let's wait for the prompt to appear.
Oh, that was nice.
Oh, tracking module.
Stored combat.
Oh, nice.
Free money.
All right, that was fun.
Now we're never gonna do that again.
all right god it's so dark okay rifle ammo need that more
rifle ammo oh are any of these lockers only one locker that
that's just somebody's takeout But they forgot to eat.
That's right.
No corner camping.
I learned that in Silent Hill.
Where the fuck?
I can't see shit.
This place is so fucking dark.
Someone find the lights.
Does he know?
There's no way he knows.
See, I told you.
He doesn't know.
That's right.
stupid no power god damn it nothing has power here
all right what's up here i am so fucking lost oh my god i
don't want to jump down i don't want to jump down okay i'm
gonna go back up here first just want to double check
everything before i go straight to hell
door here
oh my god just hate how dark this is
oh my god i feel like i can i already can feel somebody's
gonna go ugabuga booga right at me this is so oh this is
ugabuga prime time for a crank so dark.
At least I'm not Grace.
It's the little things.
It's Ashley the little things.
Thank God.
Where the fuck am I?
Where is this place?
Oh!
You will never escape the basement.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh my God.
Let there be light.
my fucking god um thank god like i don't mind fighting 20
zombies i just i need a c i need a fucking c
oh that's not the best
oh okay now i'm stuck here whoopsie oh wait i am gonna fight
20 zombies soon aren't i Wait a minute.
Welcome to the...
Wait a minute.
There's the...
Witchcraft did.
Asking you shall receive.
It's okay.
I just put the pin back.
Alright.
Oh, it's just two guys.
That's fine.
Okay, literally the fastest two guys I've ever seen.
What the fuck are you talking about?
How is he still alive?
Okay, it's fine.
I've actually lost all ammo.
Okay, it's okay.
Everything is fine.
I didn't even realize that my ammo was gone.
I think the hardest is just the fact that Like, I don't know
when to use my axe.
Oh!
Don't do.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That is not good.
That is not good for me.
Oh, shit.
Oh god, okay, it's fine.
Oh, fuck, it's not okay.
How?
Oh my god, I quit it, run.
Oh god.
Inject yourself.
There we go.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
there you go I just got oh it's okay it's all right there we
go easy all right I gotta buy ammo all right guys I might
need to buy ammo I might I might not have ammo for days no
more yeah
oh my god are you fucking okay okay one two and then oh fuck
one two there we go three swing better better better oh and
then okay the drama situation might have fucked me over
Just maybe.
No, fuck it.
I really can't be bothered.
It should detonate soon.
What the fuck?
There we go.
I didn't parry that!
That should have been a parry.
I didn't perfect parry that ended up.
There we go.
Alright.
Sharp, sharp.
all right let's see combine combine three of the herbs okay
i should make more ammo right now shotgun hand oh i need two
what can i make here handgun ammo
tracking module bucket that's literally the only thing i can
make anyway why do they have speed that's a good question
How fuck did they like learn how to make spears?
Oh, wait.
Well, I mean, yeah, because that's like the first T virus.
Baby T virus.
They wouldn't have like independent thought yet.
I don't know about the crafting menu.
I just don't need to craft anything here.
Oh, nice.
I actually need that.
Nice job.
I'll need some kind of bridge to get over there.
What the fuck?
What am I supposed to do?
Is there a fucking plank that I missed?
That not crank...
Oh my god, I didn't crank.
I didn't crank it all the way.
I didn't crank it, Soldier Boy, all the way, did I?
Alright.
Crank that, Soldier Boy.
Alright, there's my bridge.
I made it.
I made my own bridge.
No.
don't put me back in the sewage no please no oh no all right
it's fine there's loot i grab it well i'm gonna check
downstairs to see if you're right oh wait there is there's a
little little nook there what kind of loot do we have for
leon oh
it's on the other side i was gonna be like she fell for it
again it was on the other side it was like
thank god i was gonna be like
my only turkey wasn't to YouTube TLS because we all know
what Rajiv be rocking.
Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I did not fall for it again.
No shirie.
Wow, Leon, get that cardio in.
Oh my God, where the fuck am I?
Where am I?
I can't remember this.
Yep, top here.
How the fuck climb it?
Okay, I was gonna say, climb that ladder.
Oh, God.
Come on.
Do I have the crank for this?
No, I don't.
Alright, this way.
Alright, I do have the battery for this, though.
Okay, I have one battery for this.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
the underground parking.
Okay, now it's time for...
Nope.
Parking lot time.
Right, time to go down here.
Oh my god, alright.
Now to go to the worst area.
Oh my god, they could come from my left, too.
Oh my god.
Oh my my god i hate this i just can't see if i can see this
would be different
i hate
this am i hitting it i i can't am i did i hit him did i hit
him
look sometimes love has limits like did i got him did i get
him oh my god where am i
i'm so disoriented right now i can't see i can't see my
flashlight gives me like like 10 centimeters of light
worth it
that's my stuff oh god oh god oh shit no please please don't
tell me please please oh thank god okay oh my god maybe it
was not worth it maybe it was Not worth it, guys.
Could it be that maybe things just ain't worth it?
Could it possibly be it?
I don't even know where I came from.
To get to, like, the places I got to last time.
I'm so confused.
How did I get here?
Nice to turn around.
Oh my god, that was a parry right there.
Oh my god, that was sick.
Okay, I got a parry.
Do we not drop anything?
I gotta sharpen my axe.
Thank god I brought my sharpener with me.
Okay, this is worth it, and then, and then, oh my god, and
then I do that.
Wait, where is he?
That's like it, right?
You thought you could do that?
That's right!
Boom!
Get timed!
Here we go.
Get fucking timed, bitch.
Damn!
That's right, I'm gaming right now.
I might be blind, but it only heightens my other senses.
I'm like Daredevil.
Sorry, you're on your own, crazy, these Leon's lost.
honestly true are you oh my god who is right beside me oh my
god oh my god get parried oh
blood definitely bad oh don't worry i'm just sharpening my
axe real quick
oh my god wait i don't need bullets look at that shit three
parries in a row that's right gamer alert never punished
let's see I can make do I make more shotgun ammo all
right there's the other wait what wait what gun is this oh
yeah gal i don't know if i need the gal but as a large
suitable for burst okay how much what ammo does this need i
don't know i don't think i need the gal yet i
don't think i need that to be fair how do i get out of here
do i just go back from where i come from
oh there it is i knew it i knew there was a ladder here I
was gonna say it.
I don't think I can go back to where I come from.
I'm pretty sure.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh my!
Did I get it?
I can't even tell if I got it or not.
Did I got the stagger?
The parry?
I can't even tell.
Bro, that fucking rock broke my face.
I definitely need it.
There's, like, someone downstairs.
I hear them.
I'm not going down there.
They're, like, right down here.
Oh, I see him.
Do I need to...
Okay, I'm just gonna shoot him In case he fucking walks up
What the fuck?
Okay, shooting Shooting from... That's really hard Guys,
it's really hard, like you don't understand It's... I can't
see anything
You don't understand He had low ground advantage Where do I
go from here?
Here?
Oh, here.
Nothing here, right?
Alright.
He had low ground advantage, guys.
You don't understand.
It was so dark, guys.
My eyes were closed.
My monitor turned off.
I still didn't get the thing.
I'm okay wait no oh oh my god wait what oh my god I traveled
so far I it's so fucking far okay
what okay now I'm here what's
going on are these people okay
cam i'll download their data see what they saw what did they
see i got the cams the police cams that's correct sir did we
proceed so the room is retrieved that was it called dash cam
don't be ridiculous affirmative listen up our objective
hasn't changed we run Vue with the advanced party in the
center of Raccoon City then head for arc our mission is to
retrieve Elpis move out body cam yeah the body cam oh god ah
oh what the fuck headshot holy shit you Oh, what kind of
bullet was that?
Oh,
he has his own requiem.
That's not even a sniper.
helmet wait what the fuck his head is still there though
short fuse i'm playing at the game
it's walmart muskier all in good time zino god that's so
edgy like my name's gotta start with a z you're playing an
fps game against turkey absolutely give me the super chat
thinking thank you i was gonna say how the is his head still
there like Wait, I thought...
Where did he shoot him?
He's the only one whose body is intact.
Container, okay.
True, does he stop?
Okay, look, okay.
He doesn't have his arm.
But, like, he has the rest of his body.
Look at these guys.
Wait, Nick guy lived.
he didn't wait what happened to leg guy he grew back his leg
wait it's a little bit of an oversight guys they forgot to
take away the leg guy's leg he was like i swear to god this
guy was like my leg i said
first that's a big plot hole and he grew the depth free
immersion room he grew back his leg guys right after he was
like my leg my god too in it my immersion oh he swapped to a
low caliber so leon can see him or a farm like grosses thank
you super chat thank you thank you he grew it back oh my god
guys he grew back his legs
butt lick guy that's funny they legitimately forgot about
him
the guy at the end white suit can you find anything on them
yeah hold on
the database is coming up
nice yeah i'm gonna upgrade stuff i'm gonna buy the case now
i don't actually need the case
yeah the tactical team full of regenerators that's why you
have to shoot the head they grew back their legs but not
their heads guys oh
i'm fucking rich all right we got upgrade the case and then
body armor repair is it damaged i can't tell how do i know
if it's damaged or not doesn't tell me wait i don't actually
don't know if my thing is damaged
Oh, level two.
I have enough.
Wait, I can...
Should I just go for the level two, chat?
I should, right?
Oh, armor's near the health bar?
Where's my health bar?
Oh, yeah, it's broken.
It's fully depleted.
Yeah.
Should I go for the armor?
The level two armor, guys?
Is it worth it?
Or for a gun?
what is more worth it or for gun upgrade
oh wait oh it gives me like I think level two okay I'll grab
it then oh yeah it repairs my armor too all right let's save
our game I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick guys I'll
bear back
and solid bite WB Allen thank you the super chat thank you
Thank you.
Alright, let's go back.
It's time.
Let's get that.
Time doesn't exist in Raccoon City.
Thank God.
It's not nighttime yet.
I feel like you're making a lot of progress.
Okay, I need a fine way to go up here.
What is that?
Are they friendly dogs?
Stay off!
Oh my god, get parried!
That's right!
They were not friendly dogs, guys.
Because they were absolutely not friendly dogs.
Oh my god.
Okay, now there's zombies here.
Okay, now I know.
You know, I could just literally not waste bullets and just
do this.
Boom!
Ness.
That's right, Grace.
Don't you suck that blood.
Can I just?
Yeah, I have to shoot that.
Wait.
I thought I could go in there.
How do I...
There's a rooftop?
Where the fuck did that guy come from?
I'm just gonna go up here.
Grab that piece.
yeah i don't need no bullets famous last words before she
does need those bullets
oh don't grab that loot loot loot
yeah i got full hp all right for 13 bullets not as hmm Not
as good as before.
But, good enough.
Damn.
They brought in the big guns.
Oh, shit.
They were here to fuck.
And yet they still lost.
Unfortunate.
Doesn't have his head, so I can...
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Loot for days.
Thank God.
Taxpayer money.
Let's go.
yeah your tax your tax dollars go towards Leon's armory
money well spent I will say
100% worth it I'm trying to figure out which way to go I
want which way is loot and which way is objective
tax me more
where the fuck where does oh it's here all right that was
the loot area that was a shortcut area and ironically worth
it that's right pay your taxes you fund leon's armory
every every fifty dollars you pay for your taxes provides
him with one bullet a slot for crank
Oh my god, he's a shaman.
Oh my god, he doesn't have... Wait, where's his eyes?
That's right.
Wait, what?
That doesn't parry?
I thought that was a sick-ass parry!
Oh my god, he's wearing so much armor, though.
He has way too much armor on.
$50?
Yeah, but it's a very strong bullet.
Yeah, but it's $50 for this guy.
That's a steal.
Each $50 fund one bullet for this gun.
Oh my god, I can't go back up here.
This is the pit.
Oh my god.
There we go.
What?
There's no way he's gonna shoot me.
He doesn't have the momentum.
There...
What?
There we go.
Easy.
What?
How is there more?
Oh!
Okay, okay, buddy.
Okay.
Like, what's the point at this point?
Where am I getting shot?
Where?
Where am I getting shot from?
Oh my god, he literally has me cornered in this.
Oh my god.
Team Wesker was so smart.
Walmart Wesker knew what to do.
I gotta sharpen my thing.
Okay, these guys are harder than regular zombies, that's for
sure.
These guys are a lot tankier.
It's illegal.
They're wearing armor.
The zombie with guns.
It's illegal.
The zombie has armor.
Remember where all the cranks were.
Okay, I got the crank here.
Gas powered.
Which one needed the crank?
I remember.
Oh, there's a shotgun shell above I'd missed.
Where was the shotgun shell?
It's above me?
Oh, was it above here?
It was here, right?
Yeah.
Now I know.
Oh, shit, okay.
Okay, now I know what the crank is for.
Where's the shotgun ammo?
Okay, the rifle's coming in clutch right now.
It's over here.
Still has his head, I have to be sure.
Oh, he does not have his head, never mind.
I was looking at the wrong.
Where the fuck?
Oh my god, it's right over there.
How the fuck do I get over there?
Wait, this is legal.
there's no way to get up over here all right and attach the
scope I think I should at this point okay let's see how
yeah it's better about it
all right yeah it's better about the scope for this
all right okay so that's how you get the shotgun ammo one of
the parts should be just up here all right and one very
angry man maybe
I need every ammo I could get I depleted my resources or a
silly meme and it was worth it
and it was so worth it
There we go.
Is that it?
Oh, shit, that was not it.
There we go.
Easy.
What?
They don't drop shit?
Come on.
Come on, you army people.
I know you have 80 bullets somewhere in those pockets.
Come on.
these pockets are for, not for storing bullets.
What are these pockets for?
Like, what's the point?
Alright, nice.
For the pets where they store their candy.
At least let me have the candy.
At least...
Guys, we're cushioning the fall.
It's for fall damage to make sure they don't have fall
damage the military great snacks are stored in those pockets
i knew it there you go what though i didn't know that i i oh
my god what oh my god it's there oh my god oh my god I
shouldn't have taken the scope guys guys I should have taken
the scope oh
my god the sense is crazy though I will say there we
the rocket zombie
all right that should be the last zombie
where wait before i don't know where it's coming from oh my
god he's so far there is no way all right it's fine i'm safe
in here
I thought it was just sick music, you know?
Like, yeah, I wonder if I can get an angle from here.
Like, where is this zombie?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh god, oh god.
Okay, that's fine.
Friendly fire.
Oh my god.
Oh, but it takes off a majority of my HP.
Are you?
Get out of here!
Get out!
Okay, but it can take off a majority of my HP.
Yeah, I should be safe inside here.
I have cover.
You don't wait for it to land wherever it's landing.
Yep.
There you go.
I swear to God, if I see another rocket from there,
is that it?
I'm reloading just in case.
It's not it.
Now the blast, it might not be it.
It might...
No, no, you fuckers!
No!
Oh my god, he's right behind.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
They're everywhere.
I'm safe.
Where is he?
Oh, fuck, fuck.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
Don't get out of here.
Okay, I'm safe in here.
I'm safe in here.
What?
Okay, this sucks.
There you go.
Where the fuck is the other?
I'm trying to figure out where the last two guys are.
I do not have a lot of heals left.
Where is it coming from?
Okay.
All I get is loud blast.
Oh my god.
I do not feel safe.
Ah!
No!
You!
Bomber!
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
okay that's five that's five I'll just zoom me over here
and then I'll zoom me over here wait I can use the cannons
too oh my god you but then you're just gonna bomb me just
bomb me?
They'll just like return fire?
Okay, they don't know I'm here.
I hate this.
I hate it.
Honey.
Maybe.
Okay, I'll wait for the one bomb.
I just need to reload.
I literally have one oh my god oh my god it's so oh my god
wait where did you come from wait
actually where did he come from what the fuck
i mean i'll take those okay
all right
no are you fucking
Oh All right, here we go again.
Here we go again
Oh my god, I can't see him There we go Oh my god, this this
is crazy.
This is actual hell.
This is It's actual
It's just the worst part is just like
It's the fact that like, they could come anywhere.
Okay, he should...
Okay, buddy.
Okay, just do that, I guess.
Alright.
One of the cannons is right over here.
Alright, now I just don't know where the last cannon is.
I don't know where the operator for the last cannon...
Okay.
That's the hardest one.
War.
Oh, it's over there.
Oh, I found him.
I found him.
I found you.
Oh, I found you.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
My turn.
My turn!
That's right.
Target acquired.
Oh shit!
Where did this guy come from?
Holy fuck!
Whoops.
I forgot about this guy.
Okay, just to be sure he's dead dead.
That should be the last guy, right?
There you go.
Nope.
Wait, is there another?
Oh, he's over there.
Whoops.
Don't worry.
I got you.
You got me.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's right.
Get up.
Is he dead?
He's dead.
Alright, nice.
See, guys, I figured it out.
What the fuck?
Who's still shooting?
Aw, him.
Just one man.
There you go.
That should be the last one.
Alright.
To be fair, I just didn't know where the last guy was.
Okay, I didn't.
I didn't realize he was all the way up there.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, I can mortar that for loot.
Right?
Yeah, that's how I got loot for this last time.
At least these guys don't turn into blister heads.
Thank God.
Okay.
It's like here?
Alright, I should be able to grab loot.
Yeah, no, no.
They're not going to, guys.
There's no way.
Nah.
Don't be silly.
There's no way.
Guys, you're so silly.
I just want to make sure I didn't forget any ammo
downstairs.
Gotta make sure
I knew it.
Okay, I didn't waste a lot, too, which is good.
Okay.
So you go back up.
Boop.
And then check if there's anything here.
Hello?
Any loot for me?
Thank you.
Thank you for the loot.
Oh, thank you for all that yummy juicy loot.
Wait, I missed the box?
Where?
Box where?
Box below?
Alright, this box better be the most delicious loot I've
ever seen.
I swear to God.
Oh, box here.
What is it?
What did box give me?
Oh, yeah, it was pretty good.
Rifle ammo.
I should really need that, too.
Alright, back to the...
Back upstairs.
Yeah, I don't know.
I shot the dangly box, but I still need to grab all of this
stuff before I...
I assume I just go down those same path I went up.
Okay.
it should be fine all right where happened to your eyes
go grab a repair kit from container 2 and the signal
receiver got all beat up during transport we need to fix it
I just got reassigned and can't get in myself that's one up
to you graves god fucking okay all right we gotta grab the
repair kit
okay all right i gotta grab the repair kit god fucking okay
where is it why does nobody fix anything here all right fuel
okay it's back at central cap yeah i'm making my own gpu and
ram
guys the market's rough guys i gotta make my own now fucking
it's time it's time they can't catch up to me they're
climbing 20 stairs
that's right this is what the military budget is for oh god
oh god it's all the way there alright one boom two Oh, oh,
okay, it's a little slow, but don't worry.
I got a double hit just in case.
Oh, yeah, they're still walking over it.
I'll just shoot it here.
That's right.
Thank you, taxpaying's right citizens.
Thank you to the taxpayer dollars.
Yay!
Oh, my God, he's still alive.
And that's the last guy.
definitely defense tower all right do they have extra loot
oh my god you guys are so useless you guys are literally
just to like pat oh wait no never mind handgun ammo I was
gonna say you guys are just here to pad time to the point
where you don't even carry anything you don't even give me
loot
all right we gotta go downstairs for whatever the fuck is
down there wait the bodies are gone what the fuck there were
too many bodies found the signal receiver or at least what's
left of it
there should be loot on the floor see that's my suitcase I
think it's related that's all I've got why is there nothing
in that suitcase oh
Oh, nice.
Should I get out of here?
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
Now all we have to do is grab the repair kit.
And fix that shit.
Do I need a...
Do I need the fuel?
Well, we'll find out soon.
Alright, where is it?
Actually, I'll grab my stuff first.
all right nice 33 my tracking modules all that money it's
making it rain i would definitely repair our stuff all right
what's the best thing to upgrade chat oh maybe my hatchet oh
power wait i can make it even stronger i feel like my rifle
is already pretty sick No, I'm not going for the raccoon
figures.
There's too many.
There's way too many.
There's no point.
What else should I go for the upgrade?
Silence or not?
Is superior?
I'll buy that then.
Is it superior?
Can't tell.
Power is the same.
Upgrades, baby.
What should I do to...
make it better maybe power yeah i was gonna say the silencer
9 seems to be yeah oh wait wait oh i bought the silencer 9
oh my god i'm so stupid i lost track i lost track of which
gun i bought i was like was the alligator one i bought or
was it the silencer 9 i lost track i was just like which gun
did i buy what i'll sell the alligator should i sell it i'll
just store it fuck it actually no i can't store it i don't
have a suitcase should i just sell the alligator yeah i'll
sell it
selling is storing true true oh use this ammo first goodbye
Guys, I definitely used it.
I need precision.
Precision?
Precision.
I have 12,000 left.
I mean, I'll just upgrade all of this.
Oh, I can enhance it.
More power!
Fuck it.
All in.
All in on the silencer 9.
Surely that's not going to fuck me over.
All in, baby.
I love this game so far.
I didn't even realize it's been almost, it's four hours.
I could not tell it.
I've been playing for four hours.
This game has been super fun.
Not the key?
I do.
Open!
Sesame!
Oh!
Oh my god.
It's time to repair.
It's a repair kit.
Oh my god, it's a repair kit.
I guess there's also the motorcycle too, I guess.
The motorcycle is also pretty cool.
I just need to get that through the gate.
GPU N-RAM.
It's like The repair kit
Alright now we need the fuel Which is all The way up there
What the fuck Wait where's my Wait where's my gun Wait
where's my pistol Oh there it is That's gonna sit Let's
check this gun out There you go Oh Whoa, I like the...
Wait, I really like the iron sight.
Wait, the iron sight's pretty nice.
Oh my god, new zombies.
New zombies.
Dead zombies.
Boom!
New zombies for me to slash.
Okay, from here.
Yay!
Oh my god, it got punched.
Oh wait, we gotta grab some more handgun ammo.
See, how do we get to the gas station, though?
Oh, wait, loot.
Figure that out later.
This is more... Whoa, wait, how do we get this loot, though?
Wait a minute.
I can't do this to me.
There's loot right here.
Oh, is there extra loot here?
I knew it.
It's like Silent Hill.
But it's like Silent Hill.
Where, like, if you go at the very edge of the bridge where
you're not, even though there's no reason to go there, they
give you extra loot.
I knew it.
Oh, fuck.
Sorry.
Lost my balance there.
I love loot.
is there a little suspicious that there's a hmm little
suspicious there's a cat of gas there it's a sea all right
we go this way yes no head should be safe nice No head?
Thank you.
Walmart, Wesker?
It's just decoration.
How do I get to the gas station?
What the fuck?
Oh, loot.
Oh, no loot.
I forgot something?
A big container?
There's a big container?
You mean the car?
What?
What container?
Oh, was it by a propane tank?
Oh!
Okay, I'll go back.
I'm going back.
No loot left behind, guys.
No loot left behind.
Alright.
Oh my god, big container.
Oh, there's a guy in here, isn't it?
There's a guy in here, isn't it?
The foreshadowing.
There's a man in here.
Oh, there's several men in here.
Get in there.
Oh, this is bad.
Ah, oh.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, the blister heads are back.
Wait, is this better?
It's time.
Oh.
Bum, butter, dum, butter, dum, butter, dum, butter.
Okay, maybe like here.
All right, this is beautiful.
We will make rifle ammo and then put that.
here and then bump but um but um but um all right there you
go which is better wait is this the tool wait marksman a
semi-auto what does a semi-auto use is it right for that
move
yeah we'll grab i don't think i need to it's semi-auto oh
yeah it does
Fire and cartridge.
I feel like my rifle is better.
I mean, as long as I hit headshots, it should be fine.
So how do I get to the gas station?
That is the question.
There's more loot.
I'm pretty sure I grab all the loot.
See?
It's fine.
We don't need it.
Yeah, but it's locked, see?
I'm seeing up that ladder and cross it.
There's a ladder?
This ladder.
No, with exceptions.
Sometimes some loot left behind.
Some loot left behind, guys.
Ah, this way.
As long as we shoot the head, it should be fine.
As long as we get our headies.
There we go.
See, guys, we got our headshots.
I told you.
It works.
It just works.
Okay.
Shotgun shells.
Wow.
It's so relaxing to play Leon.
After 80 hours on Grace.
It really is.
It's like my retirement.
Yeah.
I fucking knew it.
You have a head.
Oh yeah, just suspiciously lying there with a fucking head
Wow Damn no head Absolutely no head I gotta fill this up
Okay
My gamer instincts was tingling
I feel like this is like grace after it.
What the fuck?
Let me guess.
You must be the town lumberjack.
It's time!
I learned from my mistakes!
Finally!
Wait.
But if I do this...
Wait, where's the other guys?
Where are the others?
Okay, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, okay, I heard the beep, beep, beep, beep, guy, and I
got very scared.
I don't understand.
I heard beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I'm like, where is...
No, no!
My chainsaw!
Oh my god, oh my god, it's dancing, it's dancing.
I can't let him have it!
I got...
Oh my god, my goddamn chainsaw is dancing again.
Alright.
Where's beep, beep, beep, map?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, come on!
There we go.
Alright, chainsaw time.
There's no more beep, beep, beep, right?
That's right, I'm coming at you!
Meow!
Leon, you can or a farm later.
That's right.
Meow!
Easy.
What?
Chainsaw versus Chainsaw!
Who will win?
Chainsaw fight!
Oh my god, it's the paddle of chainsaw.
Oh my god, Leon, you're so cool.
You're so fucking cool, Leon.
Chainsaw duel.
Nice.
There we go.
Job done.
What the fuck?
oh seven he was a good one the chainsaw's cooler yes please
all right gotta grab this thank you for your service
thank you mr chainsaw
nice Got my gasoline.
Is there any loot here?
This door open.
That's just it for one box.
That's some important box there.
The most important box of my life, apparently.
Am I missing any extra loot in here?
Where they came out?
Now we're good.
Tengi would be so proud.
The most important boxes in this game so far.
Alright, let's press our button.
How much gasoline do I have?
Okay, enough, I guess.
Just enough.
Alright, off we go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
okay that was bullshit come on come on my crosshair was
there we go wait what oh that is a lot of bullets oh that is
not good okay that that took a lot that oh okay wait that
should took a a lot of bullets.
Not a fan of that.
You'll have an axe here, so I'll wait for him to come over,
and I'll chuck the axe at him.
Or javelin.
And then I'll run over.
There we go.
Easy.
Pretty easy.
Gas power generator.
No, the new rifle is weaker that's why I didn't use it the
new rifle is considered weaker so I was just like mmm oh my
god so I had one missed earlier but I'm not going back no
way I'm going back
I could upgrade it yeah just want to grab all the stuff
before upgrade.
Okay, we got that.
We can make more rifle ammo.
We definitely need more of that.
Oh, I can...
Wait, I...
I can rotate?
Oh my god, this changes everything.
This actually changes everything.
There you go.
I actually did not realize I could rotate.
Oh.
Oh, I thought they were closer.
That's my bad.
There we go.
Not fair.
That should be all of them.
Would suck for them to turn into...
For that one guy that had shot to turn into a blister head.
Sure would be unfortunate.
That won't happen.
Huh.
Yeah, I need here to auto sort.
Where did they go?
What?
Hmm.
Look above me.
For what reason?
There's nothing above me.
Where did they...
Oh.
There was something above me.
Where could they have got?
The rats got him, guys.
It's the rats.
The rats ate him.
They were so hungry.
Their main food source, the spotters, are gone.
Oh, sorry, the Thomas the tank engine.
Whoa!
I mean, there we go.
All right, that's fine.
All right, that was easy.
All right.
Gamer time.
Damn right.
Is that it?
Oh, wait, there's a...
Oh, no.
Oh.
No, not the deep dark clothes.
Did I miss something?
Okay, I'll go back.
Back to the mines.
Wait, there's more.
Wait, which way do I go?
It's just loot.
I love loot.
No loot left behind, guys.
Remember that.
Except for that one loot.
But other than that, no loot left behind.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, shit, nice.
shotgun ammo I have 27 shotgun ammo now that should be it
that should sustain me
okay left or right all
right the sewers oh nice that's good more points for me for
my upgrades for my updates
Hello?
Any zombies over here?
I swear to God, if a zombie comes through this little...
Wait, that's it?
That's it.
Oh, oh.
There's a door.
There's more!
Okay, what's underneath this?
Oh my.
God it's a it's a ladder to another ladder okay never mind
there was more it goes deeper where are we going to now
China there's the hole to the other side
dug holes straight in the center who I
don't like this this does not bring me joy
I...
Oh my god.
I'm no pussy.
I do my own Tetris.
I play Tetris.
I don't need AI to sort my squares.
Oh no, we're back in the trains.
We're back.
We're back in the trains.
We're holding a funeral for Thomas.
Oh, whoops, I couldn't tell.
Slowly back away.
Oh, there was an axe here.
I had to headshot them.
I gotta make sure.
Gotta make no blisters here.
God, it's so dark.
Okay, I got this.
Actually, I don't think I need it, Rife.
Oh, no, I actually have to because I had to hit the
headshots so the blisters don't come up.
Oh, my God!
He's back!
Wait, actually, there is more.
I will say, I did not...
I didn't think they'd come back.
Thomas forever You can never kill a train He'll always come
back
He always comes back Oh my god there he is There he is He's
back on track Oh my god there he is There he is It's where
he got him It's where he directly guys there he is his body
is still there that's right I killed the last remaining
train oh
okay there's someone over there we're getting off track
you have your head no i fucking knew it i fucking knew it
wow all these bodies with no head yet somehow the one zombie
with his head hmm coincidence where is this area i do not
remember this place
out the one the one not headless zombie
knew it
that's right that's right i can see you right through
playing dead oh you're gonna play dead really all
right i think you got me
this ain't my first rodeo.
He's never left Raccoon City.
Alright, where am I now?
Oh, I'm back here.
I'm back where it all started.
Oh, hey, there's a container.
The undead playing dead.
This amateur hour.
Why is this way?
Fucking amateurs.
I didn't that crate?
Oh shit, no, he was in here.
Oh shit, okay.
Let's just chuck this actually.
Got me bothered.
Oh what?
Ah, fuck this.
Oh fuck, okay, never mind, never mind.
there we go
I have so much pistol it's fine
what the fuck okay I have so much shotgun ammo it's okay
alright bro it's because he was like he was jiggling okay he
was jiggle peeking guys the guy was like jiggling back and
forth.
The movements, they were unnatural.
He was sort of titing me.
Oh,
what's this?
I opened all the crates.
Ah!
Yeah, I'll fucking do that.
Ooh.
Alright, how do I equip it?
We'll put it on this one.
I don't remember what that charm did.
Okay, wait.
Only when the scope is not equipped.
Oh.
Hmm.
I don't think I need it.
I mean, there's technically a sniper, right?
Or, like, does it have to be the classic 70?
Does the marksman count?
Okay.
Oh, that's good.
Okay, I've been here, right?
I'm just gonna go back downstairs.
Okay.
Oh.
I forgot something.
Go back downstairs.
Uh, wait, there's a hand gun ammo.
Alright.
I don't want to go back via the hotel.
Just gonna go through it back here.
I already killed everything anyway.
That's right, no more pretending dead now.
Wait, I have to enter the hotel?
Hey, I'm
confused.
Imagine Grace must feel the same right now.
Sorry.
Oh, I do?
All right, I'll go back.
I'll go back to the hotel.
I didn't know I had to go back there.
I'll go back
They're just going through trauma She went through a lot
I don't remember playing as her He wants the fun She had no
gun Guys Fucking terrible I don't like that sound Does not
bring me joy I got scrap I got scrap
Oh, it was this.
I'll just grab it just because it's making noise.
Wait, this isn't even the hotel.
It was the cafe.
This is the hotel.
God, it's so fucking dark.
I hate it.
I hate that it's so dark.
I found the shotgun ammo.
Wait, I can't even go through...
Oh my god, this was the spotters.
You're liars.
You just want me to get back loot.
You fucking lied.
You just want me to come back to grab loot.
Okay, you see Thomas again.
It's all the way back here, guys.
Put no loot left behind.
With exceptions.
Did you not see the asterisks?
Someone didn't read the fine print.
I literally don't remember.
how to get back maybe like here and then is
that down or okay entrance maybe here all
right that's the outside all right we're outside again okay
where is this place all right I'm gonna go back to
upgrades upgrade time upgrades wait how much more do i have
of this game chat oh my god killed so many 49 since i last
upgraded holy shit okay i mean i'll take those still quite a
bit okay i'm enjoying it a lot though i'm upgrading my
marksman actually I need more power more power oh more wait
actually oh wait I didn't equip it more oh shit I didn't
equip it but and then I mean I feel like the need more
upgrades i think the up the requiem is like solid and
sell the classic but i can have more power
i'm not sure i have like 10 000 it's a more
power but big number dokey true true Wait, can I upgrade my
hatchet more?
I'll just upgrade my hatchet.
Nice.
By attack?
Well, it's too late.
Well, it is too late for that.
All right, definitely need more air.
Just gonna make more rifle guns.
Uh, I don't know.
I don't use light ammo a lot, so...
Alright, save game.
I'm gonna have to go.
Here.
Oh.
My incomplete bomb.
Die.
Technically I grabbed everything.
Oh, I have to go here.
Where the fuck was here?
I don't remember how it got there.
Was it inside here?
How many...
Oh my god, please.
the ambience please oh I forgot the shortcut oops
I mean like oh my god stop stop I I do not fuck with the
ambience right now it's like like yeah I forgot to open the
shortcut, so we gotta do it a long way.
I didn't realize I have to come back here.
I don't even know where the shortcut is.
Yeah, Minecraft ass ambience right there.
I grab everything.
I did.
Okay.
Alright.
Open sesame.
That should be everything.
boop yeah I did it yeah all right I can use that I didn't
use it where was the shortcut for this area oh whatever I
don't think I have to come back anyway all right I like how
there's a lot of Cubbies and loops.
Why does it feel like I have to loop around here multiple
times?
Ah.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
Might as well.
I don't like the loops that surrounding me.
The implication that I have to loop here.
The one guy that was sleeping, I got him.
Trying to sleep on the job.
That's what's gonna happen to you.
Pop, pop.
Okay.
Alright, any sleepy zombies?
Any sleepy zombies?
The way this is designed, the map design for this.
Hmm.
Wow.
Why is this place so empty?
All
right, that's fine.
I'm making you paranoid Never relax They're always out to
get you Oh yeah, yellow paint You can't just give me yellow
paint here And nothing else I
Hello?
Doesn't make sense.
That doesn't...
Oh, there.
That... Never mind.
That makes sense.
I thought it was a climbing thing.
I thought I could climb.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, goodbye, gas.
I missed the door.
It's okay.
The door didn't miss me.
Oh my god, it's so slanted.
I don't like this.
It's so crooked.
Am I supposed to go?
Not this way.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I have all this ammo.
Wee!
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's like that Pokemon game.
We have to slide to somewhere.
Yeah.
Alright.
Alright, open that elevator door, Liyah.
What do you see over there?
Wait, down I go.
Oh, it's not too bad now.
The loot back there.
Oh, no loot.
I feel like I should have, like, hid some loot there in the
very end.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit!
Alright, it's fine.
That's right.
Reflex!
Gamer Reflex.
Alright.
Oh.
I'm shoulder peeking.
I'm shoulder peeking right now.
I fucking knew it.
You can't hide from me.
Just because you're wearing a helmet.
Alright, kick.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I should actually ask you a question.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
There you go.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Okay, we had to get rid of him.
Okay, how do I cross?
I'm a little worried about crossing this now.
Oh my god, that was close.
Holy shit, that was close, that was close.
Time to find a way up.
All right.
Okay.
Didn't softlock myself.
That's a win.
Wait.
Wait, get out of here.
Over here.
Where do I?
Okay, give me a sec.
What the fuck is this?
the what the i'm so scared i'm like walking because i don't
want to break the glass
yeah i'm taking my time i don't want to break any glass
right now
like here somewhere right oh wait maybe there you go god i'm
so smart what
What's hitting me?
I don't know what hit me.
Oh my god, it's him.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my, all the way down there?
That's where I got shot?
Okay, that's illegal.
That was illegal.
I was like wondering where the fuck the bullets came from.
Oh my god, it was
literally below me.
Right below you.
Let's find those detonator parts.
Oh my god, these knees.
I don't like that.
They're preparing me for something.
Come on.
Alright, nice.
I got my detonator.
Nice.
Great job.
Now to get through that gate.
Where am I?
Yeah.
Just gotta figure out how to get down from here.
Yeah, same.
Oh, there you go.
I was like, I know, me too.
Oh, y'all kicked out of it with the bomb.
That's what happened.
Because I was like wondering.
I was like, how the fuck did I got up here?
Okay, sell the shotgun and then buy the other shotgun.
I'm gonna do that.
That's the shotgun, right?
Yeah.
Um.
Yeah, so it.
I'm going to buy...
It's attacked.
Oh, and I repair this too.
Oh, where is it?
Tacked.
All right.
More power.
That's precision.
I don't have enough.
That's fine.
Oh, herb.
I think I might actually need to buy rifle ammo.
I'm running out.
The more is the...
Oh, never mind.
Oh.
Never mind.
Fuck me.
I'll continue to run out.
Hello?
Any zombies?
There'd be light.
What's over to my right, though?
Oh, it was just loot.
Nice.
More loot.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm just going to use my...
I have too much ammo.
I think I've been stockpiling too much machine gun ammo,
guys.
Now, I'll use it for endgame.
I'll use it for Resident Evil 10.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
One, two.
I mean, it's not that many.
That's fine.
Why do I have to look?
I understand.
What am I looking for?
Oh, this?
Oh, okay.
That's easy.
Just kill all these people.
Look.
Oh.
Oh, oh, ammo for days, I say as I cannot reload my gun no
more.
Any more over there?
I mean, I got the two.
I'm out.
I got the lurkers.
I don't know.
Fuck with that.
I do not fuck with that.
that I where
are they ah steady
breaths Leon there we go what the fuck okay look he's
jerking over he's jerking off like what am I supposed to do
like he's jerking it I'm fucking oh my god he's not even
close enough for that he's not
there we go he's twerking it guys okay
that's on me I guess oh my fuck this there you go he's fell
down there's no way he's gonna get me he fell all the way
down there's no way you cannot turn into a blister head
notice how if being shot by donkey don't buy a word of a
helmet just start jorking it thank you the super chat i'm so
thank you thank you what the fuck why would i have a door
that led to a hole who designed this building even though
the building is half collapsed who designed it oh my god
i'm just hoping that oh 300 i've killed 300 zombies
I should be like legally allowed to oh my god I should be
legally allowed to chop their heads off after they're dead
like it makes no sense
all right where is he coming from
where is that oh my god what I mean that's fine like those.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Alright.
There's no way.
Who became a...
Who became a blister?
Who is it?
I hear a blister head.
Alright.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I did not expect that.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, somebody's turning.
Hello?
Tomato, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Somebody's calling for me.
Somebody's turning.
Wherever they are.
Oh, there's no way.
Yeah, I know that it's not doing anything.
but i'm just hitting headshots so it doesn't matter anyway
oh my god where is he i don't like it oh there he is oh wait
okay it doesn't matter like i'm doing headshots so
it doesn't matter if like what the if i have the scope on or
off
there you go there's one shot one kill
I'm at the top now.
What am I supposed to do?
What the fuck?
Okay, I need that.
Oh, down here.
There we go.
I didn't see that.
I made it.
Let's go.
Yeah, just get your ones.
Now for the other side.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Now I have to do it all over again.
less ammo are you ready to do it all over again yay in the
darker tunnel too yippee
all right is this where my upgrades are yeah it is thank God
okay I need to get upgrades anyway 17 kills um I wanted to
buy rifle at um everything's upgraded attack I mean I could
upgrade attack more there you go
more power no more power alright it's fine
nah SMG is getting nothing from me
hello oh
stupid How do I get to the other side?
Maybe I'm stupid.
Oh, I just fall down.
No blister heads here.
There you go.
Wait.
I shot your head!
Okay, that's not fair.
Okay, that gun's shit.
That gun is never again.
Never.
again never again I'm never using the SMG again I'm never
using the SMG again
there's no way I shot this guy's head what the fuck
yeah the S and SMG fucking sucks
all right
um excuse me but but where's that coming from?
Where?
There's a lot of flesh noises.
I do not like the fact that like, you know,
okay, that's bullshit.
I blew that guy's head off.
Like what's the point?
like
what's the point if oh no
oh no oh no run oh god oh god oh god oh
my god I'm choking right now oh shit oh There is no way
you're turning right now.
Like, I have other things to deal with.
You cannot be turning right now.
Oh, and of course the chainsaw breaks.
A fucking course.
Of course.
Yeah, I should have just needed him.
To be fair, I didn't think it'd take me 2 million shots.
That was my bad.
all right
like I shot that lady can they actually I shot that lady in
the head like I remember shooting you in the head you know
what fuck this
get over here oh my god she's still alive oh my god okay I
didn't think she would still be alive okay that now okay
nope oh all right that's fine I have an entire SMG she can't
get to me now that's fucking right the SMG finally works
that guy that woman tanked okay there's I couldn't tell.
The head looked...
The head looked so off.
I couldn't tell.
The head just looked like a scab, you know?
Didn't unplug it.
This guy can't deal.
What?
Okay.
Alright, that's cool.
Whatever.
Look, his head is still intact!
He takes the entire bullet!
That was a headshot.
Legally, it was a headshot, ma'am.
Explosives, they don't make them like they used to.
I don't think they're this way.
Yeah, he's just built... I mean, he did tank the missile.
The wreck card nuke.
He did...
He did tank it.
Ah.
Hmm.
A lot of zombies that want to jump.
We'll have to take the next one.
Like...
Oh, what?
Oh my god, oh my god, I didn't even see her.
I didn't even see her fucking jump in here.
Oh my god, I didn't see it.
I was like, where did it come from?
Where did that come from?
Fuck, get out of here.
That's right.
I'll kick you.
Alright.
I am running out of bullets now.
Oh, hey.
Hello there.
Oh.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
That's right.
I'm going to...
Damn!
Tickets please!
No ticket!
Get kicked off the tram!
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay.
Okay, I saw the head.
I was like, that's not good.
Uh, sharpen this real quick.
Give me a sec, sir.
me let me let me sharpen my axe real quick before you grab
me
oh sure is leon one bullet to make it count i don't know if
i made it count
oh my god he's so lucky i ran out
Oh no.
Oh no, I kicked too close to the sun.
Oh no, this is bad.
I actually kicked too close to the sun, guys.
What the fuck?
I can't see it.
I actually can't see nothing.
There we go.
I don't run.
I fight.
That's right.
Loot.
See, everything is okay, guys.
Oh my god, I'm climbing back up.
Where is that?
Where is the noise coming from?
Oh my god, it's right in front of me.
That's right.
here.
I'm a fighter.
Boom.
I ain't scared.
That's right.
What you gotta do now?
Nothing.
I'm running out of ammo.
This might be bad.
Fighting back might not have been the smartest thing.
I ain't no coward I just gotta figure out where to go now is
this way see it was worth it I showed those zombies
damn right I showed those zombies what's up yeah reloading
that took longer than planned Luckily, I found a bike.
It should make up for lost time.
Oh my god, it's bike tab.
Okay, where is it?
Okay, we're gonna grab our upgrade stuff.
Alright, what can I get now?
Alright, upgrade tab.
Oh, Jesus.
I've just been...
I never stopped shooting.
And I fired again.
And we're selling the gale.
Fuck this.
Actually, that's the...
Wait, is that the machine?
Yeah, that's the... This guy sucks.
And then we'll grab the...
The Revo.
We might as well... Oh, I didn't grab this.
And...
Let's actually upgrade this a little bit.
Let's give it a little bit more und to it.
Uh...
I don't think we need more ammo.
Let's grab.
Precision.
Like, I think everything else is, like, A, okay.
Oh, more power.
More power.
Always more power.
Might as well grab all the rest.
Eh.
Just because I have the money for it.
Alright.
Time to grab the bike.
Where?
Oh, we have to do this.
Sorry, time to detonate the bomb.
We got the one thing I was doing the entire time.
Time to detonate the bomb.
And then we grab the bike.
Beep, beep, beep.
Nice.
I did it.
I did my job.
Yeah.
God, are you so cool?
Oh my god.
Look at me go.
Oh my god, I need to pull up a gun.
Oh my god.
Okay, at least I upgraded my SMG before I go.
Can I move it?
Oh, I do move it.
Oh, oh my Nimi.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Yeah, I got my motorcycle.
Wow.
God, he's so cool.
What the fuck?
Victor?
No, don't ruin this for me.
Don't ruin this.
Oh my god.
That's okay.
My aura.
What the fuck?
I don't think they're good boys.
Maddie, thank you for the gift of ship.
Thank you.
Oh, they don't look like good boys.
This bitch keeps getting burned by her.
Okay, I have unlimited ammo.
It's okay.
Oh shit.
It's alright.
Okay, reload!
Reloading!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's alright.
They just want to run with me, guys.
They're just running with me.
Alright.
Maybe I should have upgraded my SMG before we...
Maybe.
Oh shit, hey, that's Victor.
These pups could use more training.
Yeah, you do.
Yeah, not so...
so scary now, aren't you?
Oh, but bullet.
Meow.
Oh, my God.
I'm drifting on the roost.
The roost of Raccoon City.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Bam, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
Same game with Grace, by the way.
I know, what the fuck does Grace have?
I don't know if I can go back.
No, they give us Super Chat.
They can take us.
I don't know if I can go back to Grace.
Why is he so cool?
So much for the direct route.
Where do I go?
Do I shoot that?
Okay, nice.
So Michael Bay's shit.
right now.
I make my own routes.
There you go.
Damn right.
Sears.
Sears are just an option.
I forgot about grace.
There I got him.
I got to get the dogs too.
Rezone.
Oh my god.
The dogs are body him okay it's fine by my entire pocket is
just ammo seriously I don't give up that easy what the what
the fuck is going on what what the fuck what what is driving
gravity has it no there's rules and gravity for leon physics
don't apply to me nice really
nice that's right the laws of physics don't apply to leon
let's go rules of nature
he's so cool Oh, shit.
No, his axe.
His unlimited axe.
Gravity is just a theory.
Oh.
That's smart.
No, don't let the mode.
Come on.
Meow.
Oh, it's a motorcycle.
Oh
Modern day jousting That's it That's how he dies They're
jousting She don't want a helmet God he's so cool He's so
lucky, cool.
I can't believe, like, we were introduced to the Victor guy,
and that's how he dies.
That's how he dies.
It was a cool duel, though.
Leon, you're not wearing a...
He doesn't need a helmet.
Those rules don't apply to him.
Oh, I'm running out of gas.
Oh,
that's true.
He is sick right now.
There's only 50% of his power.
He got black mold in his lungs.
All right, search for grace.
That is so true, guys.
I almost forgot.
This is him nerfed.
Mad scientist thought he was an action star.
Nerd got wrecked.
I know right try to try to be Leon bro stay in the lab stay
in school nerd cuz Cindy thank you the super chat thank you
thank you you don't gotten that aura who's crazy grace who
oh my god this is the longest I've ever played as Leon don't
take me back you can't do this to me This is the longest.
I've got to be cool.
I get to be cool.
Back where I came from.
Go back to the town where it all started.
The RP.
Oh my god.
RPD.
I'm back where it all started.
Where it all began.
When he was a twink.
He's got two nerves.
The infection and his marriage.
Star Ace, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
It's all you now.
Oh, Marvin!
We're ex-givitiya.
The very first time you encountered Thomas the Tank.
engine oh the pts oh my god that's oh my god the memories
we're finally home
marvin you think marvin's body is still here sherryman rpd
it's been a while since you've been back there
It's the OG music.
Bomb, bomb, bomb.
It's like the BSA set up HQ here.
A typewriter is
still there.
Oh my god.
That's a shitty ass bomb.
This bomb fucking sucks.
The fact that this...
Welcome, Leon.
The fact that his banner is still intact.
That bomb sucked.
No wonder it didn't kill off anything.
Fucking guy.
Oh.
Grace.
Shit.
She's in danger.
They knew Jack's shit.
Sure, I found Grace.
Leon, we come.
someone's been expecting us
huh gotta lock on our location better than no aren't they,
isn't she just gonna move alright save why don't you just
move though alright guys, how close are we I'm playing until
they send me back to Grace but how close are we to the end I
need a no how close how close Around three hours?
How much more of Leon do I have left, guys?
Give it to me straight.
How much more do I have of Leon?
Before they send me back.
Before they send me back to Grace.
A lot?
Oh, very little?
Oh, Grace, oh, it's only a very tiny bit.
Okay, wait, all right.
Let me read a bit of lore around here.
From our survey of the grounds, we pinpointed some location
that still have viable resources.
The armory has leftover supplies.
Gun shop out back.
Working shotgun.
You mean I can finish this in three hours?
Hmm.
You know what?
I'm enjoying this game.
No?
Oh, 15?
Okay.
Maybe?
You know what?
Let's go.
Let's commit to it.
Fuck it.
I'm having...
Okay, guys.
Guys, I need to know if it's going to be three hours.
Oh my god, it's the lion.
That was a weird puzzle.
Oh my god.
I never miss.
Wait, I missed the...
I don't know, I get to duog.
I get to du-be Leon.
The towers pass by so fast.
When you actually get a gun.
I'm sure down.
Oh, this is where we...
Rise your power?
I swear to God, if there's still power, that's...
Shit.
Need to pry this open.
This... The government didn't do a good job bombing Raccoon
City.
I will say that.
Record record two hours, six minutes, I believe.
Goggles, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was going to say.
Champions of Justice.
Are you ready?
Duty, cause.
And you're an artist.
It shows what you got.
Make sure you use the banner.
The stars.
Oh, wait.
This is the.
Oh, these are all.
Wait, is that not the same?
Marvin.
Wait, was this not all the same stuff from?
Oh.
From before.
Oh, seven.
But I'm...
Alright.
Okay.
I'm lost already.
Locker, locked, rusted.
There has to be hidden zombies here.
The bomb didn't do jack shit from what I've learned.
Return to this station.
shelter one the refugees yeah it's literally the same the
same lore from two i remember that note yeah where's claire
where is claire that's a good question i remember that note
i'm the table which table there's no tables here
This...
I am a little lost.
What the fuck?
See?
He's gonna turn to a blister head.
He's scripted.
That was a headshot.
He's gonna do it.
He's gonna turn.
He's gonna fucking turn.
How is that not a headshot?
This is a scripted zombie.
there's no way
I can't axe I can't axe him
if I axe him enough look the angle was not on purpose if I
axe him enough maybe he'll wake up as a blister maybe
I told you the bomb did nothing I Waste of tax-paying
dollars.
Actual waste of tax money.
How the fuck did that not break?
Oh my gosh, library.
How the fuck did these guys, this clothes survive too?
Okay guys, now I'm not sure if I can complete this game.
I'm already...
So lost.
Ooh.
Oh.
Mechanic jack.
Okay, that can open the shutter.
Once I check the shelf.
What the toy?
I don't care about the toy.
Anything actually up here?
Nah, nothing important.
Cross the bridge.
At the top, cross the bridge.
Right shelf.
I mean, that book over there that's just hanging there?
What?
None of these shelves work.
Across the bridge.
Yeah, I can't do anything about it.
Oh, this room.
Wait, I came from this room.
Oh my god, I'm so lost.
Just like the good old day.
guys just like the good old days all right so me was that
should just do it for next stream all right guys let me open
this all right we'll do a pull chat I'll make a pull for you
guys to decide if I continue or not start a put finish it
today finish it today or next stream oh my gosh or oh my god
so slow or oh my god come on
today next stream was a saturday was a saturday or friday i
don't remember my schedule guys
scheduled next Resident Eva.
I just read this.
I will go and explore a little bit more while Vodazing is
up.
I'm lost.
I'm already...
God fucking...
I'm like, where do I go?
I'm so lost.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna go up.
Oh, I didn't go here yet.
it
oh the spooky oh wait is that the armory nice all right
there should i don't know if i left anything for us here
what's here you kids have fun solving oh my god damn berry
he fucking left us in canada to canada god damn it berry
wait oh yeah i was gonna say there's i don't think there's
anything in here.
I fucking sucked up all the loot in Resident Evil 2.
Oh.
Hey!
It's her hat!
Oh, that's cute.
That's cute.
I love all the little references.
Training and training plan.
Join Jill.
Pick the girls up.
Yeah.
That's cute.
Oh.
Ah, fuck.
Okay, I don't know.
Unless somebody knows.
Unless someone knows.
Ah.
Oh, there's everybody.
Good lives needlessly lost.
With the Elite Stars member.
Wow.
I wonder how...
Wait.
Oh my god, this...
Okay, this is up here.
No, up.
Yay!
Oh, shit!
Offers limitless bullet increases the firepower?
Oh, it's for the Requiem.
Oh, my God.
Limitless bullet penetration?
Holy shit.
Nice shades, Wesker.
Alright.
Man, I'm a genius.
Figure it out the code.
Keep inspecting a drawer in Wesker's office?
Holy shit.
Oh wait.
Medical benefits of herbs.
That's it.
Nothing else in the office.
I'm pretty sure.
Wait 30 seconds?
Why?
A book?
Okay.
Back to the library.
Alright.
Now look at the drawer.
Okay.
It's better be worth it, guys.
There's some benefits of herbs.
Okay.
Rising.
Okay, you know what's...
You know what I realized?
Somebody moved this.
Because in the original game, it was in Wesker's office.
So, while the bomb was dropping, somebody was like, we gotta
keep this photo safe.
And...
move the photo move the photo oh something is rising i love
padlet someone moved the photo to the library to keep it
safe because it wasn't originally here oh that's where the
rr comes with this that wasn't the photo's original spot so
who moved it
who in the rpd moved the photo when everyone was evacuating
from the police station my man it's gotta preserve it you
know all right that's a good place to call it
Haloroth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
We'll complete it next stream, guys.
Oh, it was almost 50-50, but we will complete it the last
part.
Next stream.
We made a lot of really good progress, guys.
We really did make a lot of progress.
I've been enjoying it a lot.
Understand why this game has, you know, when I get to play
Leon the entire time, I've been having a great time playing
this game.
You can tell where the fear starts and where the fear stops.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Marvin used his last bit of life to move that foot up.
You got to keep it safe.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's surprising whenever they put a gun in my hand that I
start fearing.
I start being less scared because can't be scared when I can
hit my shot.
anyway guys I'm gonna call it here thank you all for
stopping by thank you again to Nimi for the raid I'm gonna
go grab dinner now I'm gonna get some kimpop I actually
ordered some kimpop earlier today for lunch but I was like
but I couldn't finish it so I'm gonna finish my kimpop
anyway guys hope you guys had a great time watching as
always everybody stay hydrated posture check Get up and move
around and get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'm looking forward to tomorrow's Pokopia.
I should have my Switch.
My Switch should be outside my door right now.
Because I did say it was going to deliver today.
So I'm very excited.
I'm pretty sure a lot of people are already posting spoilers
and stuff.
Because Australia got Pokopia first.
I didn't do the cheese where, you know, I get an Australian
person to buy me Pokopia.
Because, like, I didn't have my Switch 2 yet.
It should be like outside my door.
I just got to unpack it But I'm pretty sure Already a lot of
people are playing Pocopia right now Yeah, and JP players
too But I'm excited to explore Pocopia with all of you guys.
Yeah, it's a new Pokemon game It's a new Admiral crossing
Pokemon game that has one point higher than Resident Evil
Requiem in reviews It's literally I think like Resident Evil
Requiem is like 89 out of 100 and Pocopia was 90 and it is
the current most the current highest rated pokemon game of
all time um even higher than all the mainstream games have
come out over the years um and also like mainstream and the
spin-offs too so i'm excited to check it out tomorrow and i
always love animal crossing um and like slice of light type
game so i'm pretty excited hey guys as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check blood flowing you stand for me head
to bed because you deserve it it's down to 88 well it's one
point below resident evil now it's still it's still pretty
high hey guys i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys